This is the weapon. This is how institutions
trade. When I teach this to people, they say
you're crazy. This strategy has 75% winning rate.
And with this strategy, how frequent would you say
trade opportunities come? This one has one or two
trading opportunities in the day. That's why it's
so important to understand what happens there.
Why? Because are you ready to take a step beyond
order flow into institutional order flow and
options flow? Or no one better than Freddy Siento,
a 20-year market maker. I use this strategy to
pass funded accounts. I can put 10 ENQ contracts
so I can make $6,000 in one move. I truly believe
every retail trader, whichever strategy they have,
they should know about this. You don't necessarily
need to change your strategy, but it will help
you to increase your winning rate. It's kind
of the base of everything. In this episode,
he holds nothing back as he breaks down exactly
how to use options flow as a retail trader and
more specifically even as a prop firm trader. I
realized my edge is to enter the market when the
big guys enter the market. I was hedging $1.5.
What does that equate to? $1.5 billion. With
that big amount of money, I moved the market. I I
move it a lot. I sold another million dollars and
Goldman Sachs was there. If a Gold Bman sax is
there, I gonna reverse all my position because
over two hours of institutional insights from
a true institutional trader. Have your notepads
ready for this very special episode on chart
fanatics. We are just starting to get this
knowledge that institutions have and they don't
share obviously. And one Italian guy, he told me,
Freddy, that looks illegal. And I say, well,
I think a best place to start because again,
this is a topic that is extremely extremely sought
after right now. And I think this might be one
of the first videos going out on a major platform
that can go really quite in depth. We're going to
spend a little bit of time on the whiteboard, but
we've have a full presentation breaking it down
step by step, uh, which I thank you for. But just
to get things started like why is institutional
order flow and and specifically options flow
why is that so important to traders today?
um I think is um is so important because
actually the especially on indices like S&P,
NDX, Q's, ATFs like Q and SPY what's happening is
um institutions like um pension funds endorsements
uh mutual funds after I guess 19 um when when
the crash 1987 the black Monday when the market
went down 22% in one single day. They realized
they need to hedge. If they don't hedge, they're
going to be, you know, wiped out as happened at
the time. And just happens that in 1973 um the
Chicago Board of Exchange, they launched the first
um option contract, a standardized option contract
is the same year when Black and Schles, you know,
these guys, the mathematicians and great guys,
they they come up with the pricing model. So from
that moment on the market they start to realize
they need to hedge their portfolios. If you go
around the world um pension funds, endolments,
mutual funds, everyone they are loan let's say
the market but they need protection right it's the
same when it's the same way you have a car you buy
a car or in your house you need to buy insurance
right um so before that these guys didn't have
insurance they just you know long and and when
things were very bad they just wipe out um then
we had the uh 200 uh.com crash um and and that I
think that was when when all these you know big
guys say we need to hedge we need to use options
which is if you think in a in a nutshell options
is like insurance. Mhm. Yeah. for them. And now
what's happening nowadays? Well, it happens
the com then the 2008 crash uh where I lost
everything. It was a great experience. You know,
you learn a lot of course. Um was that your first
personal like you know trading during a crash in
that environment? Yeah, I was working in Australia
um as a junior broker and and it was great, you
know, it was you know being there as a junior
broker seeing inside how big clients our clients
were from Europe. Um you see many things like
the importance of the VWAP for instance all these
guys came and and placed the orders and bigw and
basically I start to see the markets are playing p
as playing poker. They're playing on the what you
saying the VWAP. Yeah. Yeah. Um and also you know
putting orders, taking orders, learning everything
inside was amazing. But then the financial crisis
came and and you know everyone lost their job,
companies went crash and that was a great
experience. But what's happening in the market
I think after that people start to realize we
need we need to hedge our portfolios, right? And
and that's been an explosion of that. um what's
happened and as we're going to see here um in 2021
before that you can trade options I don't know uh
three days options a week options you know months
so people were trading those options to to find
protection other people found it that was a great
great as um product to actually uh speculate
in the market because it has an asymmetry like
you pay small premium and you can take 300 300 400
returns. So that's that's um I always mention like
um Nicolas Talev in his book um antifragile he
basically say if the only way to make um wealth
you know to make money in the markets is when you
trade an asymmetric product yes and options are
asymmetric product you know you pay small premium
you can have 200 300% returns so I guess other
uh market participants start to come into the
market to actually profit from that. But what
I really think changed everything is 2021 when um
the SEC, the Securities and Exchange Commission in
United States, they say we're going to um allow to
trade zero DT options and and zero DT options are
options that actually start to trade at uh 9:30
when the bell rings in New York and basically they
expire at 4:00. So that's that we will see that
those options are crazy like the guy who's in the
middle the market maker he needs to hedge that
trillions of dollars immediately like you know
quickly and and without thinking nowadays they
do machines. When I was in my time, I was trading
um for this investment bank in London. I was
market making um outrise swaps in the foreign
exchange market and it was billions of dollars,
sometimes like two jars of Euro dollar, two jars
of sterling, they came and I had to hedge that
in the market and I realized sometimes I moved
the stock the spot market it moves because of me.
I mean not because of me because I was hedging.
Mhm. So in the options space is the same but with
zero DT options is like exponential. Yeah, if if
you imagine as I I tell to my um you know the guys
I coach, they say imagine when there were two a
month a week auctions the market maker we will see
it is is hedging the hedging pressure is like you
know the guy is driving a car at I don't know um
80k an hour so it's very slow he can turn he can
turn very easily but with zero DT options he's
like going in a F1 car Ferrari so he's going 300k
per hour. He need to put the brakes in a curve
and then steer the wheel 300ks again. So that's
that's that's kind of a that's not the difference.
So the volatility has increased. I don't think the
volatility has increased actually there were a
lot of say pressure into the pressure for the
market makers. Understood. And the best the funny
thing not the funny I know volatility in options
is a different meaning. It's vogue right? Yeah.
I'm learning. I'm no and and it's it's actually
there were some papers at the time that says that
oh zero options is going to create huge volatility
in the markets but actually it's the other way
around. They have kind of come into the markets
and stabilize the market somehow. Um and nowadays
if you think about what is happening now how the
world is changing I truly believe all these you
know hedge funds uh portfolio managers they used
to come into the markets into the options to
hedge their portfolios with one month three
months options I think now they do it in zero well
see what happened with um United States and Iran
um before that was the um the war between United
States and China the tariffs. Yeah. The tariffs
and you know the world is changing very quickly.
The speed of reaction is necessary. Yeah. So if
you have a portfolio it's interesting would
you say that the zero DTE almost helped to
facilitate or was created to facilitate this speed
of information because if we go back to when you
were sort of doing the institutional market making
the speed of information even then was slower than
it is today. Yeah. Even though it was faster
than say the '9s or the 80s, right? Back then,
even the information was so slick. Before the
by the time a retail investor knew about it,
it was already priced in probably a week before. Y
while now it's instant almost and therefore having
the option of zero DTE allows the funds allows
even everyday people to be able to, you know,
hedge and be able to maneuver a lot faster which
is necessary for the markets of today. Yeah. Let's
take a break for a minute there, guys, cuz a quick
word from our official platform sponsor, Ninja
Trader. If you've been following along on this
channel, you know how much time we spend breaking
down charts and market structure. And Ninja Trader
is an awardwinning futures trading platform built
for exactly that. You get advanced charting,
depth of market tools, and market replay,
so you can work through historical sessions
and practice in a fully simulated environment,
all without risking real money. Here's how to
get started. If you're new to the platform,
use the link in the description below to download
Ninja Trader and explore it in the simulator. You
get two full weeks for free to test everything
out. And if you're already trading prop,
choose Ninja Trader as your platform at checkout.
It's the best platform for the job. So, go check
it out and let's get back to the episode. And
and that's where big opportunities for us retail
traders come. Um because I truly believe every
trader, retail trader, even trading options or
trading futures with wherever whichever strategy
they have, they should know about this definitely
because um you know Fabio Fabio Valentini great
great guy friend great friend um we've been
talking about his we've been talking about these
zero options he's implementing in his um kind of
strategies and and and It's actually it helps you
don't necessarily need to change your strategy if
you have one which is already uh working for you
but it will help you to increase your winning rate
and to reduce your losses which we will see how.
I love that and I think that's a perfect segue now
that we've set the stage of you know the history
and the importance of uh this institutional flow
and options flow in particular. I think for the
whiteboard here. Yeah. Why don't we just help the
audience visualize, you know, what this flow looks
like. Okay. Um and then we can take it from there.
Yeah. So, um as we said before, um all these
institutions, pension funds, endowments, mutual
funds, name it, all around the world, they need to
hedge their exposure, right? The the best example
that I always tell is JP Morgan. They have a hedge
fund. um is 22 billion dollars hedge fund. Wow.
and they come into the market every three months
to do a call which is an option strategy to hedge
their hedge fun which they use it with auctions
and people if people doesn't know about these
things it will it will be the day when they say oh
my good they got the market today was very crazy
very tough but well you didn't realize it was JP
Morgan you know they they they basically sell um
we will see they they sell a fall far away on the
upside, they sell a put far away on the downside.
When they sell options, they get credit, you know,
they they they get the money and with that money
in the middle, they buy a put to protect the 22
billion portfolio. I think that was the last time
I saw it a couple of months ago. And each node
was like 40,000 30,000 contracts, which is a lot.
It's is massive. So that creates a pressure
in the market that creates a pressure on the
market maker who needs to hedge this and that's
we will see they go into the futures and that's
where you see this price the last time the market
went up up up up and didn't stop. So people with
kind of mean reverting strategies trying to sell
this market they're going to get so many losses
only by knowing this you know as as I said before
they reduce the stop losses. buy because if they
knew this they just don't sell the market because
they know you know it's not the environment it's a
big guy with $22 billion portfolio hedging in the
market and I don't go against that but um to start
with the white board um so you have all these
big institutions right they need to come into the
market they have to there is um they are forced to
yeah they have to they are forced to so they come
into the um they come into the market, right?
Um and they do it through options. Okay. So,
they do it here to options. Okay. Um this works
very well in indices. So, and and there is a
reason for that. We'll we will see it. So, they
come into the S&P um and they come into the SPY.
Yeah. They also come into the NDS, which is the
one I love to trade. Not the NDX, the the futures.
But I love what's happening in the NDX and
obviously the QQQs. Bear in mind this one, these
guys are professionals, you know, they are top of
the top. Um, and when I say top of the top, I when
I was uh working in London here, um, usually
you go out and, you know, with your broker,
you met other traders. You know, I felt so little
because most of these guys in the big banks,
they were um they have degrees in maths, physics,
PhDs. I, as I told you, I have two M's degrees,
but these guys were like, you know, the top of the
top and and you're like, my goodness. Of course,
as if you're like a different language almost.
Oh, yeah. But but they're great guys. But um yeah,
that's that's what I tell to people is, you know,
people who comes into the market to trade a moving
average. And I'm sorry to people who try moving
with Irish and that kind of thing. First of all,
they need to realize where are they getting into,
you know, they for me when I go into the market
every day, I I said myself that I going to go
against the the the brightest minds in the world,
right? So So I I respect the market in that sense.
But anyway, um this is what happens. These guys,
these institutions all around the world, they
come here to trade options, right? To hedge their
portfolios. Yeah. One difference with um um and is
this is two-way. Okay. Why? Because in the middle
we have the market makers. Yes. Right. Um what is
the function of the market makers? What they do?
They provide liquidity. They provide liquidity to
these guys. Okay. So when you buy when you trade
options and and one of the nice things of options
is you can buy uh you got calls and you have puts
right and you can buy them or you can sell them.
So it's like four um if you see it's like four
ways to trade. It's not like futures that you
buy and sell. Here you can buy protection but you
also can sell it. Yes. Yeah. And from this you get
hundreds of combinations. Yeah. Right. You can do
butterflies, colors, credit spreads, name it. You
can take these four u dimensions and you can do so
many uh configurations, so many structures. Well,
I think that's why when I interviewed Jim Carson,
we were just talking. Yeah. He mentioned that
zerodt options and options in general are kind of
like a new technology in a sense. Yeah. probably
because of these combinations that even any other
type of asset class doesn't really allow. No, you
know, yes, you might have more leverage there or
you might have these different elements, but in
essence, it's just buy and sell. Yeah. Right. Uh
versus options has all the Greeks involved and
then there's all these combinations that allows
you to get very creative with your structuring
of a trade and an idea. Yeah. Probably one of
the best um podcast that you did that I love it
was um what is it? IMRA IMRA guns IMRA guns IMR
yes yeah and and I love what he mentioned you
know when the markets are going down he's got
a strategy to sell options and and the analogy
is like if you if you if your house is in fire
how much are you going to and if you got a house
and you buy a fire insurance how much it's going
to cost you but if your house is in fire how much
is going to cost you yes you know so so so that's
a great way to explain you this options is is
a complex product, but is it it allows to these
institutions to create so much, you know, and to
do so much. Mhm. But we're going to get to the
point where we're going to trade futures on this
and I promise. So, we got these market makers,
right? So, basically, how they make their money,
they they they don't take positions on these guys.
Yeah. They just charge the spread, right? That's
their job. Yeah. They charge the spread, you know.
Um if someone wants to buy a call, they sell it.
Someone wants to sell a call, they buy it from
them. You know, same with puts. They act as the
counterparty. Yeah. And and what what I realized
from thinking of my job here in London is they
they can't say no. You know, whatever flows cames,
they have to provide liquidity. And I remember in
my job, I have to I I I couldn't say no, sorry,
the market is not right right now. No, I have
to provide liquidity. Even if I don't like it,
even and that's the advantage of retail trader
compared to an institutional trader. We have to
I have to have a position every day. I have to
be hedging everything. While you're a retail,
you can just wait as we're going to see for
the right moment. But anyway, these guys,
they charge the spread and and they manage
they need to manage their portfolio. Yeah.
One of the things with options is and let
me put it with an example here. Let me put
in this color. When someone buys a call, this is
the call profile, right? So this is the strike.
So when the client buys a call at this strike,
he pays little money for let's let's say little
money, it's a little bit for the for the premium
and he's got an exponential um uh probability of
winning or he's got like this exponential exposure
which is called I'm going to put it here because
we're going to see a tried to explain it as
as we explained before it's called convexity.
Yeah, this is a such an important concept that we
need to understand and convexity really means that
if you trade futures and the futures market moves
let's say 1% and Q the same move this is just for
academic purposes it's not like the real of course
but if someone trades NDX or QQQs he's most likely
it's going to have like 300% Yes. So that's why
another reason why the options are so attractive
right now and they're increasing as we saw in the
slide that I show you. They are like exponentially
increasing the the use of options and people
trading options. Futures traders, it's time
to hear about Apex Trader Funding, the largest
futures firm in the industry. They have completely
changed the game with their new evaluations. So
far, they've already paid out over $600 million to
traders around the world just like me and you. And
not only that, Apex actually holds the record for
the largest payout to traders, which is of course
with Jadecap, no stranger to chart fanatics, with
$2.5 million in a single payout. And the person
before that was Trader Kane with $2 million in
payouts. Now, what sets Apex apart? Apex, you can
get up to 20 accounts which no other firm offers.
Now, not only that, they have extremely clear
rules with their revamp. There's no MAE rule,
no 5:1 risk-to-reward rule, no hidden rules, no
gray areas, clearly defined draw down models. So,
you have two options now. End of day draw down and
intraday trailing draw down. which means no payout
denials, no payout reviews, no discretionary
decisions, and no surprises. What sets them apart
as well? Traders receive 100% of approved payout
requests. Up to 20 accounts, as I mentioned,
and one day to pass. Now, the other thing that I
love about Apex, not only can you get 20 accounts,
but there's different account sizes. So,
they have 20K accounts all the way to
150K accounts. So you can get 20 of any of the
account sizes that you choose. Not only that,
you have various trading platforms from Wealth
Charts to Trade of Rhythmic. The choice is yours.
So make sure you use the code CF to get up to 90%
off on evaluations right now using the link in the
description below. Trader Apex today. Let's get
back to the episode. But so that's that's that's
an important moment. That's why people came.
Now what what we're talking about the market
maker is like on the other side the market maker
which is selling the call which is is the profile
of the call. Listen if if this client something
happens and the price didn't go up he will lose
the premium. He will be like tiny compared to you
know this convexity. But look for the market maker
he lost a lot. basically his has unlimited losses
exposure. So he can loss everything. Yeah. So
that's that's that's kind of an asymmetric race.
So what what is he doing? So basically he's he's
happy to provide options flows. He's happy to
charge the spread, but he needs to hedge this
because if he doesn't hedge his exposure, his
risk, he could, you know, bankrupt his company.
So basically what they do they they they are the
market makers right. So what they do and as we
saw in this in the in the slide basically they
they have a portfolio of options right all these
options they're put in their portfolio. Yes. Okay.
Okay. They're happy they charge the spread. Now
they need to manage this. How they manage that
with something called the Greeks. Probably you
have heard about them. Yeah. Right. So the first
um and this comes from Brad Shaw's pricing model,
the one that we were talking in 1973. Mhm. Um it's
kind of the base of everything because they say,
"Okay, now I need to hedge this race. I'm happy
to do this, but I need to hedge. I don't want
to lose money. My job is not to lose money. My
job is to provide liquidity, charge the spread,
make some money. I'm not going to go against these
guys because this could be one of the greatest
minds in the world, you know. So why are going
to go against against them? So that's not going
to happen. So what they do they use the grace
and the first is the delta which is like that.
So basically delta tells the market maker listen
as long as you're delta zero don't worry because
market can go you know something could happen
and and as long as you're delta zero you're
going to be h okay so as we saw in the slides and
let's let me put it down here this is the market
maker yeah with the unlimited losses potential
from the selling of the call. So basically delta
is telling him or or that Greek is telling him
listen if you go to the futures market and you
buy let's say this is NQ this someone trade NDX
so the underlying spot from the NDX is NQ so if
you go to the market and you buy NQ given by delta
that's okay why because it doesn't matter if the
option goes down you are going to be h so your
P&L is going to be zero. You are going to lose
money on the options but because of the hedging
buying futures if the market goes up you bought
futures so you're going to hedge your exposure.
Understood. In del in terms of delta what impacts
you know delta being zero or not like what does
it represent? Um, we will say in a minute, but
as I told you before, zero DT are like these guys
are driving a Formula One car and they have to be,
you know, the the the amount of money that they
need to hedge in the market is huge. Mhm. you know
and the the thing that zero DT are in the market
now allow us day traders in futures and options as
well to actually have and as as we saw in the
we will see in the examples you know to take
amazing trades like with very low risk. Mhm. Okay.
Why? Because they need to hedge this quickly with
a lot of money. So the price get to the level
when these guys are positioned and the market
maker needs to go and buy hundreds of thousands of
contracts on ENQ and that moves the market. Okay,
but anyway this is this is kind of clear. So
this what is this this is what this guy market
maker is doing. Yes. Okay. In order to be delta
hedge. Okay. And this is just an example because
as I said before options buy calls uh this these
institutions they buy calls sell calls buy puts
sell puts. So basically this guy has a portfolio
right and he needs to constantly be hagging all
these positions. So the first great um the Greeks
that he use is delta and he say okay you know as
long as you're delta zero you're fine. Um so
what's happening then sorry is um market moves
you know markets are not static they're actually
moves and if you let me do it on on the on here.
Yep. Um all these bricks they have um a shake
right so this shape of a call is something like
this right it goes from zero to one. This is this
is the delta of an option. Now if you think about
this as this is price okay and this is delta
okay price moved up which is right price move
uh down which is left okay so the price is going
to move now this guy let's say here he was delta
zero okay but for any reason the market moves up
now this is x0 sorry mat I'm going to get into
a little bit of maths no I like it um so this is
x0 where the price is delta the neutral. Mhm. And
now the market let's say move from this price to
this price. Yes. Which is X1. Okay. If you see the
delta change. So his delta is not zero anymore.
Okay. So he needs to calculate the market maker
needs to calculate the move of this. He needs
to move. He needs to calculate this curvature.
Yes. Right. So we use maths or they use maths. And
basically if we calculate the slope of these two
points. Okay. Right. Which we use with the second
order derivative. Probably you remember them from
a school or when we were studying derivatives.
So this is this is the second order derivative
which is called gamma which we represent like
that. Mhm. Or we can represent like that doesn't
matter. So what's gamma? Basically gamma is the
change. This is uh the math representation for
change which is the same as delta but doesn't
matter. Oh no sorry we need to the change of
delta right okay with respect to the change of a
spot price you see so the spot price is changing
yes I promise this is going to have it's going to
make sense when you when we before when you were
you know doing this as a market maker you would
have to do these formulas you could yourself if
I'm not mistaken right no that that that's the
advantage of being working for an institution
that okay um you have a team of quants you have
they'll be doing it yeah they will doing it but
you need to understand it yeah but what I mean is
at one point it was a manual process it's always
been always been okay yeah we'll put that bit
out no you you to be honest um the job probably
these guys are not going to hate me but the job
of an institutional trader is easier compared
to a retail trader really Yeah, because you go
everything. You go I have I remember there were
like three coins, you go three economies, you go
it, you know, I need one more screen, they put it.
I need one more, they put it. And and basically
is is you got everything, you know. So your job
really is then to just execute execute and and
manage and have this ability to to to do it well,
be calm under pressure. Mhm. And Yeah. and and
because you got everything now as a retail is
very difficult because you don't have all these
resources course you have to study by yourself
and and for just to point out the obvious question
that people may have at this point is that they
may go well this seems a really complex no worries
it's going to get to the point where we're going
to trade it very easily no I like that no what I'm
getting at though is you know because I understand
the desire for simplicity I understand and the
desire um because it's much easier to manage
and and try and implement. But the reality is
that we are trying to trade. One of the hardest
things you can do in life is trade the markets,
right? And to be disciplined enough to follow
an edge and and create edge and identify edge.
So you know I've be come to the understanding
over recent years of interviewing you know people
like yourself and others who are professional and
institutional traders is even though they may be
as you say professional institutional traders to
your point that you just made right now is as a
retail trader it's going to be difficult right
and the way to make it simple is to spend the
time to understand complexity and to understand
and and take the time to research and learn
y it will become simple after. Yeah. Right.
But you shouldn't be put off by complexity or
something that may seem difficult to understand
because that is the challenge of a trader is to
put in that necessary work and to figure out the
puzzle pieces, if you will, of the markets that
are available and thanks to people like yourself,
Freddy, who are opening the eyes and giving that
education entirely for free here. um you know the
the option if you to use a better word the option
to learn is never been greater. Yep. Right. Um,
and I'm only st pointing that out for anyone
who maybe is up to this point and think, ah,
you know, maybe I don't need this because I
would rather use my moving average or my support
resistance and just follow my technicals. When in
reality, you know, having this understanding, yes,
may take research, yes, may take time, but the
understanding that you will have at the end of
it is far greater than anything else that you'll
have. And as to your point, Freddy, through having
this knowledge and through practice, you'll get
to a point where you'll have lower stop- losses,
you know, greater performance and increase your
win rate. And at the end of the day, if that's
not the goal of every trader, I don't know what
is. Um, but I'm excited. So, not to take you off
off a different tangent. I wanted to just take
that moment quickly. That that's that's totally
right. You know, as I say before, um, you don't
need to change your strategy. Exactly. Yeah. But
if you if you know we this is I I promise this is
going to come down to levels in the market where
uh you see a level which is a we call it or it's
been called a cold wall. Yes. For a reason because
the price is magnetized to that level and then
reverse. Mhm. 36 seconds. That's Prime's fastest
payout on record. Not 36 hours, not 36 minutes,
36 seconds. The average payout time across the
entire firm is 34 minutes and 98% of their payouts
clear in under an hour which has been verified by
Deote. That's exactly why they just won fastest
payout prop firm at the UF awards. Most firms make
you wait weeks and you still have to pray and see
if you'll get it. Ola Prime CFDs pays you before
your coffee gets cold. And that's why you should
trade with Hola Prime for your CFD accounts today.
you can get a massive 30% off using the code CF at
checkout. So, make sure you go check them out with
the link in the description below. And let's get
back to the episode. So, if you have a strategy,
let's say many people use the 30 minutes volume
profile where they wait for the price to to break
up that value area high. Yes. Right. And and
and I did it with um I asked my permission to
Fabio if he contact and he said, "Yeah, yeah."
We were trading together one day and I remember
his strategy one of his strategies is something
similar and it was a cold wall just there and
I was we were trading and and he took the long
because his is his strategy with certain winning
rate which means he will have losses eventually
or he's very good at break even. Yes, he is.
Yeah. Um and I said he took the long and he said
Freddy what do you want? What do you think? And
I say like I'm thinking to take a short he said
why? said because it's a cold wall just there 30
ticks where you took the loan and he immediately
put himself in break even he you know he's he's
a guy who like to learn he's amazing yeah and he
put his um break even price 30 40 ticks touched
the cold wall I took the short position and the
market collapsed and and then in the same way one
day he took a short position on on his strategy
and and I didn't do anything and he said what do
you think and I said like implied volatility skew
is telling me the price is not going any lower. I
I I don't have the crystal ball. I'm not a guru
or anything, but we will see that as well. The
the the volatility skew is telling me the implied
volatility of these options on the bottom. The
market is not going any lower at the moment and as
is showing. So he took profits and then the market
reverse and and rally and as I say like that
that's a nice example why because usually people
take a short position and once the market makes
a new structure on the way down they take the
stop loss in profit you know far away from where
the price is and then they waiting for the price
to continue lower and then what happens the price
reverse and they lose these amounts of of profit.
If you knew options, if you knew there is a put
wall, if you knew that the implied volatility
or the skew, the bull skew is telling you
that the price is not going any lower, you
will take profits on the bottom. And that's what
Fabio did. He took profits right at the bottom.
when we have a look the the bullish cube and the
price value and that's everything is down to this.
uh I encourage everyone doesn't matter your
strategy just spend some time to learn this
because this is what's moving the
market right now and the wave of
uh gamma exposure I don't like to call it gamma
exposure as as Jim Carson say because everyone
now say oh gamma exposure gamma exposure and
you got so many system like gamma exposure it's
not really only gamma exposure it's the whole
flow of options you know implied volatility bq
volatility surface that we need to talk about
that as well. It's all this complex that actually
is expressed in certain levels that you can
actually help you to maximize your profits,
reduce your stop- loss or I I think I am a options
flow trader which trades futures based on options
flows. Um but anyway, so what's happening now?
Imagine you're the market maker. This is a good
example. You're the market m market maker. Yeah.
And you're providing liquidity to all these guys
which are as I said before they're the brightest
minds in the world and your risk is on limit. Yes.
And this is this is showing that your risk is on
limit. So you covered your delta which you done it
which is this one. Now the price is going to move.
Okay. Now you need your second order derivative
which is gamma. Mhm. So gamma is telling you uh
the change in delta with respect to change of a
spot is going to give you a number and companies
like the one I work with this um guess what they
translate that into dollar amount. Okay. Why try
to replicate what the market maker needs to do.
So now second part market maker needs to go and
trade his gamma. Why? in order to be delta neutral
again. And how does it look here? Okay, let me
create another color. So it means that he let's
going to put a number so people understand. If
you already bought half a million dollars, right,
in futures trying to hedge this position as
the price move higher, he needs to go and buy
more futures. Okay. So, probably GMA just to put a
number is telling him uh you know what you need to
buy another 200K. Okay. And is that because of the
slope? Yeah. That it's indicating. Yeah. The the
the price move the delta is going to increase.
It's going to increase and to keep it neutral.
Yeah. You need to increase the position. Yeah.
So, he needs to go and buy another 200,000. So,
he already bought 500,000. Now, he needs to buy
200,000. And this is where the overlap for those
futures traders out there. This is why the options
flow already is well is already understood from a
foundational level. But now we're starting to see
really the specifics here because then once you
start to understand, okay, we're going to start
seeing an injection of futures orders coming in.
You're I guess as a futures trader, your job is
to try and follow along with the market makers
institution. Well, it's kind of the byproduct of
the institutions, right? And and I realized this
uh when I was market making derivatives. I I used
to do outright which is forwards and swaps in the
foreign exchange market. Um one day I can it it
was I I know people say there is no aha moment in
trading but I was hedging I'm I can't say what
client but I was hedging 1.5 jars of sterling.
So that's that's a lot of money. But that
was a der that was a client who came into
the derivatives market. Mhm. And if you think
derivatives market is just a PayPal. So the guy
the client not the guy the client he told me
Freddy I need to or I need to buy 1.5 jars of
uh What does that equate to? 1.5 jars. Uh is uh
$1.5 billion. Wow. Um in derivatives, right? So
obviously I have to do I didn't have to I have
all the systems for me I calculate the present
value say okay the pres okay I'm going to do it
but because these derivatives uh they have time
with this so it doesn't mean that he want it now
it means that okay I want to buy 200 millions in
a month 300 millions in 3 months and like that in
different times you know different moments in time
in the future. Mhm. Okay. Okay. So I calculate
everything bring the cash flows to present value
and I need to cover my delta this one here. Y so
basically my delta is saying okay I going to sell
to this client this amount of money on this
time in the future. So what's the most liquid
uh or the the liqu the calculation involves the
underlying which is the spot. So it makes sense
for me to go and buy the spot already. So I
buy the spot to delta hesh and then when the
time comes I give it to him. Yeah that's in the in
the foreign exchange but we I have to calculate my
delta and in few occasions I noticed with that big
amount of money I move the market and I I I move
it a lot like like and and I thought to myself
like no I mean I press the buttons but it was
it was the institution like me as a market maker
who moves the the spot market. Mhm. and and then I
realized this is a nice hedge. I never I'm sorry
I never believe in indicators uh these kind of
things because they're lagging. And when I when I
when I did that for a few times I realized my edge
is to enter the market when the big guys enter
the market. Yep. You know because they're going to
move the market. Um and and I and I have that in
my mind for a long time and I I always tell this
to people. So I have that and then when I was
trading because I I was um trading derivatives
and also sport. One day I was in my platform
which um the minimum amount was 1 million. So 1
million euros 1 million sterling. And there were
certain moments in in the market where you see
there is activity. And I remember one day I sold a
million dollars. Um that was Euro dollar and that
was Goldman Sachs on the bit and I said okay. And
the market start to tick up I sold another million
dollars and Goldman Sachs was there and I were
like okay I going to sell another million. So if
he Goldman Sachs is there I going to reverse all
my position and I going to put my cell long. So I
sold the million. So it was three million already
and Goldman Sachs was there. So based on on what I
did, I was like on my experience I'm thinking so
I bought 8 million euros to cover my tree and to
be 5 millions long and the market just so that
that moment I thought like if I have a trade
retail it has to be with something like this.
That's going to be my age. I don't want to trade
lagging indicators. I don't want to trade moving
average. It has to be I want to be in the market
when the big guys are in the market. was but you
know and this is comes to that so now we know the
importance of gamma right what so gamma and gamma
the importance I'm sorry the importance of gamma
is if you think about it the price move up let's
start from from from from zero the price move
up right so an institutional an institution came
make transactions in options market maker provide
liquidity market maker put those options in the
portfolio and then they need to hedge his Greeks
right by hedging his race look what he did first
he bought half a million this is just educational
numbers y so basically he moved the price a
little bit up right so that's why maybe this
price move from x1 to uh sorry x0 to x1 but then
his delta change so he needs to go to the market
and buy more. So this is like self reinforcing.
So who is moving the market is not anyone else but
the market maker himself. Mhm. You see he buy he
moves the market up and then his delta change so
he needs to buy more. Yeah. So he's actually there
are moments and you see in NQ maybe the market is
just going up and up and up and up and that's like
kind of snowball. The guy is buying because he
needs to be delta hedgeh. When he buys the market
moves up and then his delta change so he needs to
buy more and then when he buys more his delta
change so he needs to buy more. M this is just
one example because at the end of the day he will
have a portfolio not only a call but he will have
a portfolio calls and puts long and short but this
is something um more um deep into into analyzing
this but um at the end of the day he will have
this hedging pressure in the market. Okay.
Now he will have his gamma obviously. Now we
have another order uh second order derivatives
which is um we can talk about charm and we
can talk about bana but we're not going to
talk about them because these are very important
for long-term options like one month three months
options and probably with the interview with Jim
Carson he told you about opex the important of
opex and what is called the triple witchings right
so when opex comes is the the the as of that last
week when the options expire like this kind of one
month, 3 months options and these two second order
derivatives are one are very important because
they create magnets in the market. They create
levels where which is called pin effect. The
market goes to a pin effect come back it doesn't
go down then come back again then come back again
because this second order derivatives charm is
with respect to time. You see we've been studying
everything with respect to price. Yes. But charm
is with respect to time. So basically charm is
telling the market maker this option is going to
spar today and how much money you need to hedge
in the market not with the move of the spot but
with the move of time because at the end of the
day at 4:00 that option is going to value zero.
The price of that option which was 300% at some
point is going to be zero. Yep. Right. And bana
is with respect to volatility. Understood. Okay.
So we trade um I I I trade the first two hours.
That's it. Um because of this it doesn't make
sense for me to trade beyond that. Beyond that
and and we will see why there are some academic
and professional studies of what happened the
first two hours in the morning. Um institutions
position themselves in options. Yep. Then it comes
that that's what I'm so against. Sorry gurus. Um
when it came to the retail war, people were say,
"Oh yeah, there's no liquidity because the
traders go for lunchtime." And I was thinking,
my goodness, I was having breakfast and lunch in
my desk and never kind of it were no time because
I have to be there. So it's not because we go to
lunch, it's because a different flow positioning
and and all the structure that we seen. Mhm. So
anyway, um I don't look into this too because we
trade zero DT options and for me it's enough to
trade the first two hours. We are learning still.
So we are learning how to trade charm but charm
is very difficult because at the end of the day
close to 4:00 is a lot of hedging you know a lot
of hedging speculators options this these options
are going to spar so it's very difficult it's not
as predictable as trading delta and gamma I trade
gamma actually during within the first two hours
and then during the day bana doesn't change that
much like the volatility from the options doesn't
change that much which is quite different from the
volatility of of retail traders use ATRs and all
these kind of things right so if you think about
this is what's happening and and and this is
the whole structure now the job that and this
is pretty new this basically start to make sense
from 2021 so it's only five years compared to I
don't know b your bands and all these kind of
things that has been for decades decades so we
we're still learning a lot but what we have now
is enough to uh understand for me if you ask me
this is how the market works and and this has made
sense in the indices because most of these guys
come for hedging. Mhm. Right. They have to they're
forced to. That's why I like your interview with
um Imbra because he said he you know I think
he's very knowledgeable and he said they have
to they're forced to. Yep. Yeah. What are your
thoughts? Random question, but we're going to
see potentially a significant change in the
next couple months depending on you how the
market reacts, but we're going to see single stock
futures come in. Yep. Do you think we're going to
see is this information you think going to be
start to be applicable? People are already are
doing it. Really? Yeah. Because the actually um
so I know you have single stock options. you got
single stock options and this is pretty similar
what's happening there and so do you think that
we may even see an increase y when single stock
options uh futures sorry comes along y because
a lot of uh you know we see occasionally the the
indices see a bit of choppy price action a lot of
people may then look for the single stock futures
for that volatility and those movements yeah but
you know what you trade this that's what you want
you want volatility that's what I mean so like and
you see those choppy days, people then may take
their sort of opportunity and start looking at
the single stock futures with the same premise
being able to see the flow within options over
to the single stock futures then potentially. I
think so. Yeah, I I I this is this makes sense as
I said before because institutions came to h so
that must be the same reason and people you know
they always will come very clever people who say
oh I can profit from this. Yeah. you know and and
we do profit from this you know because as I said
before at the end of the day this is uh going to
be translated in few levels this yeah I was say
the same yeah I know but I love what we've done
here and I think it's extremely clear uh and we've
taken this step by step and I'm sure let us know
right now drop a comment like how do you feel at
this point in the video drop a time stamp and say
um you know just answering that question of you
know in terms of the foundation do you have a
good understanding but from here we're going to
actually pull out the laptop full presentation
breaking it down step by step. Um so we'll do
that. Now what I was thinking is we'll keep the
whiteboard out just in case when we're explaining
uh from the presentation if you want to visualize
anything or draw anything out at least the options
there. Um and yeah, we'll take it from there.
So now we're going to go through this presentation
going step by step more in detail of exactly what
we've covered so far but then actually as Freddy
said how this boils down to just levels within
the market. So I'm super excited. Um and where
should we begin then here? Well, I I I named this
presentation for you, the hiding architecture that
drives the financial markets because everything
that we see here, we actually going to see it um
down to what it is to trade, right? Um and for me,
the market's always been a puzzle. You know, I
always I was lucky enough to be an institutional
trader because I never I I as I said before, I
I never believe on these uh indicators because
I did actually I did a um um data analysis and and
I go like 11 indicators. I tried to um mix them up
and and I got like 10,000 or 7,000 combinations
and none of them were good. Yeah. So I feel like
this is doesn't work. So it needs to be something
else. And and I was I say I was lucky because I
came into the markets trying to solve the passful.
I never came into making money. But I was lucky
because I was working for a bank. I get my pay. I
get bonuses. I have insurance. I have you know I
I didn't have that need to you know make money to
survive. Yes. Which allow me to actually start to
think you know I want to solve this puzzle. I want
to really learn what moves the market, why these
big guys, Goldman Sachs, JP Morgan, City comes
into the market and moves when you know when I was
um Do you feel like having that need to make money
can sometimes distract us from trying to figure
out the puzzle and instead of the puzzle we go for
whatever the quick fix of making money is? Yeah,
unfortunately now that I've been retail trader
for uh three and a half years, I guess is is is
you see the need for making money, you know, and
and you see the quick and it's a a human nature,
the need to make, you know, um learn things very
quick, learn very fast, and just tell me the the
pattern and I make money, you know. That's that's
but that's very human that people you know people
sometimes they're tired from their jobs they they
10 hours working and of course and they and they
probably hear someone oh you know this guy make
a million dollars in the markets this guy made a
million so they they okay I want to make a million
dollars but if you think about it um I I love the
process where I am now it's been more than 20
years and I'm still got a lot to learn. Yes.
you know, well, that's what I was going to say
earlier as you know that example we talked about
like not being scared of complexity, having that
student mindset to learn and evolve. Um, you know,
and and yourself is a great example of that, the
examples you gave of Fabio, a phenomenal trader
in his own right, but yet still a student of the
game. Oh, yeah. And you know he even when I post
trades and I'm by no means you know a phenomenal
trader and I'm trading FX using technical patterns
and you know nothing complex but he will when
I have had some trades he will ask me questions
about it like you know that sound that's a great
entry how did you do that what are you doing you
know and that shows you the the elite traders or
the ones who can put themselves into that bracket
they never stop learning you know and that's not
to say hey they're changing the strategy all the
time it's just a case of constantly making sure
that they're doing their best making sure that
if there's a puzzle piece missing or they don't
have an understanding of, they will at least learn
it to have an understanding, should it be usable?
Should it be something that provides better edge,
better risk management, you know, better uh, you
know, take profits as we talked about earlier,
like these little things, they seem little, but
they're actually Yeah, exactly. That they seem
very minute, but in the grand scheme, that's
the bigger picture. Yeah. Exactly. and and and
you know um talking about Fav again he he when
actually I was teaching him to uh these options
close to him and he was very he said look you know
it's going to take me 6 months 7 months to learn
this I like that yeah and and he was you know and
and he was very kind to get me uh let me staying
um get into his uh you know he's got a course
he tra he teach people and he was very kind to
you know let me in and I talked to the community
and and and he said like, "Yeah, it's going to
take me six, seven months if I want to learn how
you sculp, right? And how because the idea is to
maybe combine everything with his style. Although
I got my own style, but it's learning, you know,
never never stop learning." Um, so anyway, for
me is is the puzzle like solve the puzzle always
has been how can I solve this puzzle, right?
This is what we already saw here. Yes. So at
the the end of the day, what's going to happen?
You did a great job. You you did an amazing job
of drawing that out honestly. Yeah. So, at the
end of the day, what we want as a futures trader
is to be able to trade futures based on all this
information, right? And that's it. Get our trades,
make our money. We have a deeper understanding
now. You know, we've heard a lot over recent uh
months. This is being recorded in uh mid June.
Yeah. 22nd of June. Uh but over recent months,
you know, we've been hearing a lot about Jane
Street, right? and how much they've been making
been making as a market maker. Um and it's
very interesting now we have a bit of a deeper
understanding of you know how they're going about
doing that. Yeah. and and and also it's not that
that I I I just learned they also they yes they
provide liquidity they don't take positions but
they have a portfolio right but if they're very
long in deltas which is a concept where we will
see if they're very long in deltas in certain
levels of the market they will reduce the implied
volatility of the options at that level and what
it means is In the options market, supply and
demand play a big role. Mhm. What is considered
as a cheap option or expensive option plays a huge
role because prices tend to move or the options
market tends to move where cheap options are of
course and we will analyze that in the volatility
surface. All right. Um so this is at the end of
the day what we want to do is here we want to go
into the futures and be able to profit from this
knowledge. Okay we already mentioned who are
they they are they don't take positions they
just provide liquidity. Mhm. Now zero options the
options that had been introduced to the market in
2021 nowadays they represent 60% of the daily
S&P volume and the whole indices right that's
very important and that we we'll come into this
because that's that change the game right but also
why options are so important so I got this graph
for you this is this is the increase in options
volumes, right? And the projection in the future.
Oh, wow. So, if you see the the dark blue are the
options um equity options and the green ones
are options on indices. Look what happened at
2021. They start to get explosive move and the
projection is even bigger. I I remember when I
was looking because I I need to look a lot of
data in order to if you see this is a process
which has been taking more than four years maybe
understand this but um at one particular month the
options market grew like 300% monthto monthth wow
so that's huge um to put it in I like to put you
know easy things so this is the options close
if you see these waves this is the futures and
this is the stocks and so you can See the options
flows huge. They are huge. They they they're huge.
Um this is a a year-to-day percentage of zero DT.
They went from 21% in 2021 when they were launched
to nowadays 63% of daily volume. Okay. And bear
in mind what I told you before in ser options
market makers are driving a F1 car and they need
to hash very quick. Okay. Um, I I just put this
because it's important. Um, in October 2025, last
year, it was a record of 110 million contracts
traded. October 10th. That wasn't October 10th.
Was that when Trump wasn't there? Yeah. Yeah. I
can't remember, but it was around there, right?
It was around that day something happened and and
that was a record day. M and for us for our you
know futures trading on September 3rd 70% of all
options volume were zero DT. Wow. What doesn't
really mean if you if you if you think about it
daily we trade $3.3 trillion on volume. Wow.
Imagine 70 60% are zero DT. Imagine how much
money the market makers need to daily hedge
in the market in the futures right. Um so that
actually telling you okay the moves that we see
in the futures are not actually random you know
um I remember when I was studying there were this
discussion between these scholars in many papers
markets are random no markets are not random when
you see this this is okay maybe markets are not
random okay and if we somehow manage to follow
that dealer hedging the market maker hedging
Maybe we can profit from that, right? Because
it's it's huge money. Okay? And remember,
more than 60% are COT auctions. Keep that in mind.
Okay? Now, imagine knowing before it happens,
you know, that moment where the market maker needs
to go and buy hundreds of millions of dollars in
the ENQ. Mhm. That would be I mean for us that
would be amazing. It would be of course it would
be take the subjectivity of the market you know
because markets people trade not the markets but
subjectivity on some strategies you know like
like trading this well this is what everyone's
hunting for right certainty they want certainty
and we're not saying this gives certainty but
it allows you to have a very direct insight
because that's what you hear probably loads
of retail traders say I want to trade like
an institution I want to trade like a bank
But then what they do is then take these a
lot of the time it's gurus but just general
you know sentiment from social media of like this
strategy is institutional this strategy is the how
the banks trade right but this is actually where
we no one has to say it we can look at it we can
you can see it it's in the math of the market
itself and and I'm going to give you a tip and
we will see in a minute how the institutions
work trade is analyzing the volatility surface
which we will analyze it and we will trade on
that. And so right, we have the structure. We
know this guy for me this guy moves the
market. And it's funny because when you
think about what we seeing here um you know
in the retail world there are you know you see
um uh market manipulation. This is how the
institutions manipulate the market and they
show a graph where the price go down and then
rallies you know these kind of things. And then
from my experience it's not like that. It's it's
like I immag says institutions they're forced to
come into the market. They don't care about the
retail. Honestly, I'm telling you 100%. They don't
care. They don't care about the stops of the
retail. They don't care about this liquidity.
They just need to come into the derivatives
in the options market to h the portfolio.
Maybe they need some levels right for accounting
purposes, for hedging purposes. They kind of,
you know what, I want to do a caller on this
level, which is what we talk about like before
JP Morgan W, which hedge fund. They need to cover
22 billion position in SPS. So they come into the
market, they analyze with the quant team and say,
"Okay, I gonna make this caller to h my exposure."
But it's they, you know, it's $22 billion. They
don't care about retails. Yeah. Exactly. Right.
And that's just the nature of human nature in
terms of where people are placing their stops are
just going to be in in the path. Yeah. You know,
that's just the natural order of things. Yeah.
Exactly. So now we're getting closer to to solve
the puzzle. We need to understand first of all
this mechanical influence which we already kind
of see it of market makers hedging these zero DT
options and they go into the futures. Why? Futures
are liquid the most and and I always remember Jim
Carson say you know that's the perfect way to
hedge your exposure. Why? Because they're so
liquid. That's why you know when when he p on X
he put a cross on a bananas. You know the monkey
want his bananas. It's just this. That's where you
find your bananas in the futures markets. And then
we need to understand the volatility surface.
Yes. And I I urge people don't leave. Don't be
afraid. I going to try to explain it very easily.
And this is how institutions trade. Institutions
don't trade moving areas. They don't trade cross
you know the night moving average cross the 20 the
20 the 50 and then I take the position. No, they
they trade using the volatility surface. Okay.
Now what's the mechanical influence on zero?
We already saw it. Um when we see the first
order derivatives, they need to hedge their delta
and they use the second order derivatives gamma
u to keep hedging as the market moves. And when
the contract is going to expire or very close to
expire, charm the second derivative tell them you
need to hedge certain amount of money because time
is running out. Yeah. Yeah. Um and then banner
volatility but as I say before this is dependent
uh volatility dependent and what we do in in day
trading sculping we volatility doesn't change
during the day so we don't care but people who
trade options they should look into bottom okay
now this is what delta looks like we already saw
it but what's important to know is zero options
If we have 5 hours for the price or for the option
to expire, y this is going to be the the profile
of delta. You see is is soft curve and we already
saw that you know that's what the market maker
this is going to be translated into dollar amount.
Okay. But look what happened when the market when
we have only one hour. So it's exponential.
Yeah. And and it changed the slope. So what
it means is as time passes the market maker needs
to be more aggressively. He needs to hedge more
aggressively. Okay. And also when the price
get to an important level he needs to increase
the h. Yeah. And that's when you see these big
moves into the market. They get to a level and
then come back. Yep. That come back is what we
trade. And it has a logic, a mathematical logic,
right? But this is this is what happens in delta
neutral hedging right we already saw this and
it's like okay this is the client buying the call
this is just an example this is the market maker
taking the other position selling the call so he
needs to to be in order to be delta neutral delta
zero he needs to buy ENQ futures understood yeah
liquidity that's where they find the liquidity now
second order derivative price move. Price is not
static. So he needs to use his second order gamma
in order. This is translated in dollar amount. All
right. This is going to tell him how much money
he needs to keep hedging. Yeah. So that from your
example earlier for educational purposes original
position 500k this is then going to dictate okay
I need to add 200. I need to add add accordingly.
Yep. And it's very interesting when you analyze
calls delta and puts delta when the price get to
a certain level the market maker is buying buying
aggressively. It gets to a level and then you you
see the market kind of not collapse but reverse
a lot and everything has to do with this analysis
of delta calls and puts. Okay. Now I know it's a
lot of um kind of maths but I'm going to try to
explain this very quick. Okay. Um the blue line is
one month options to expire. So this is an option
who is going to expire in a month. Yeah. If you
see they kind of exhibit a normal distribution
which is really soft. What it means? It means that
the market maker in his hedging you know going
into the futures and hedging is not as aggressive.
M it has to be self hedging. Why? Because the
option has time. Mhm. And probably you have heard
from your other um interviewers here that options
are uh they have three dimensions. Yep. Yeah. They
have implied volatility, strikes and time. So time
is very important for options and and basically
this option the market maker doesn't need to hedge
it that much. Now as we get close to expiry the
green one is going to expire it in 3 weeks. Now
you see that the the curve is compressing right
when the option has three days is the yellow one
and the zero options had this kind of it's called
in mathematical terms leptocartic shape you see
extreme peaks yeah what it means is market maker
needs to be very quick and very aggressive it goes
back to your F1 example right so this is I like
the F1 example So um um the mechanical and this
this is the kind of technical words given by um um
the the mechanical hedging obligations generated
by zero DT options are by any institutional
measure massive in a scale streaming gamma
which is this is streaming gamma concentrations
and executed at machine speed that's the words
from Mandi Su from CBO research. I don't know
if you're going to if you're going to get into
um into options flow, you you have to follow
Mandy. She's you need to reach out to Mandy.
Yeah. Ah she's actually uh Jean Carson interview
her. Oh really? Yeah. Yeah. In his in his book
in his podcast recently. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. So so
she's very knowledgeable. I'm subscribed to her
um weekly um newsletter newsletter. So basically
this is the research from them and I put it here
because so people to understand this is not me
this is not something that I you know I came
to my research no this is people who has been
researching this with time okay now we need
to understand volatility surface we understood
now how the market actually works right and the
structure and the and why market makers move the
market now we're going to get to the second part
which is I mean the aim of everything is to get
to a trading you know to the trading where we can
trade this and we're going to show it but before
that and and giving what you say before this is
how institutions trade they and and honestly I
never look at moving average in my life when I was
institutional trader I never look at that because
it didn't make sense to me and so it's it's is
it's is it's a term volatility surface everyone
hear about volatility surface and for some people
especially A future trade is a mystery. You
know what that thing? Yep. But is is this is
the weapon. This is how institutions tra and this
is the symmetry knowledge from an institution and
retail. You know, retail. Unfortunately, we have
all these gurus, gurus, you know, selling courses
$8,000, $5,000 for okay, let's going to try a
berban. I'm like, oh my goodness. And us. Um
now I tried to explain this and I was thinking and
I was talking to um the guys from Guess which are
the you know after Jim Carson I think they're
the most knowledgeable person to understand
this. It's two guys John he's um he's kind of the
maths guy he trade options and and Jazz he trades
futures. Oh no. So I think in pandmia combination
in pandemia they they get together and they they
know the market they know this structure from a
to so they got together and actually um guestbot
which is the platform that we use in order to see
this I'm going to show you later they develop for
themselves they never thought they going to sell
it or anything they or they made it for themselves
understood. Yeah, the tray, right? And and so
I was talking to John before I came and I said,
"John, how can I explain this so people don't get
and he came up with this amazing idea?" He said,
"Listen, there are two types of traders,
right?" Sorry, no normal traders, but the
traditional trader, what he does with all his
strategy is like looking at the clouds and see,
okay, it's a gray cloud, it's windy, you know,
in countries like mine, you see the birds flying
and a normal trader could say, okay, it's going to
rain. Mhm. Or maybe it's going to rain because the
clouds are miles away. Mhm. When you understand
the volatility surface and its relationship with
price is like seeing the same clouds but have an
instruments to say okay this is the air pressure
this is the wind conditions this is the humidity
all these kind of really advanced tools that can
actually tell you with more more precise more
probability actually it's going to rain. Yeah.
So if you think about this is the difference from
the traditional retail trader and an institutional
trader, right? Yeah. Similar example, um Andrea
Jimmy when we did our our chart fanatics, he was
like the difference and that he's referring more
so to order flow but with a mention of the options
flow. Um similar example is like having just a
normal gun, right, just with a a red dot site.
Yeah. Versus having like thermal scope and night
vision. and target tracking and everything. Um,
it's having that level of detail to make a more
informed decision based on actual data versus just
visually looking uh maybe at technical analysis or
even as you mentioned uh use of indicators. Yep.
A lot of people try and rely on indicators as if
it's that data you know when in reality this is
the data. Yep. Yep. So it's volatility service
that data essentially. Okay. Understood. And and
and there is a relationship between volatility
surface and a spot price. All right. We we saw
it in kind of second plane you know what what's
happening. But the volatility surface being a
three triangal um we will see it how actually
help us to trade. At the end of the day I guess
everyone is kind of waiting. Come on give me the
trade. How can I trade this? But at the end of
the day, this knowledge is important in order when
you're going to trade and we see well we're very
lucky. We have a very good audience who you know
really appreciate the depth. I believe for the
most part ever so often you see a comment like
ah get to it but reality being as we mentioned
earlier listen we we could show you levels but if
you don't understand those levels you it doesn't
mean you're going to doesn't mean anything to you
and honestly a race I truly believe every single
trader should notice because it's going to help
tremendously doesn't need to change their strategy
um as Andreas has an strategy volume profile you
measure 15 or 30 minutes you know same as Fabio
you know is it's not that change the strategies is
to have some you know like lenses like vision you
know I'm usually I take this long position oh wait
a minute this is a cold war you know I'm not going
to take it exactly or as you mentioned earlier
taking profits taking profits letting some come
back and and losing out exactly so um if you see
this is this is the um um volatility surface Okay.
And the volatility surface is 3D because you have
implied volatility on the vertical axis and then
you have the price the strike prices and time. So
that creates that kind of surface. Okay. Now the
thing what happens on why is this is so important
when someone an institution came and they need
to buy options. I'm not saying a call a put he
needs to buy auctions. he's buying volatility.
And actually, if you talk to options traders, they
don't trade uh direction. They trade volatility.
Mhm. You know, they they they don't care. What we
see, what we know here is they don't care about
um direction. They just trade volatility. Yes.
How far is going to get there? Yes. But it's
going to get really quickly or it's going to get
really slowly. Okay. You know, that that kind
of things. And and that's what they care. And I
remember when I was an working here in London. Um
I love options. Always love options. Actually,
that's why I'm in the markets because um when
I was at junior, I did very well in options. And
then um I was in the in the desk with these guys,
the options guys in in here in London. And one
day I was sitting with them trying to understand
things and they say, "Look, you see these options?
We put in the draw, we close the draw, we don't
look at them anymore." And I was like, "Why?" He
said, "We just don't care. You just whatever it
goes up or down, okay, we're safe." Mhm. You know,
and and I found it amazing because, you know, what
you trade, what I trade or what we had learned
before is, oh, it has to go up or has to go down.
But never I don't care where it goes as long as
it as long as it moves or doesn't move that quick.
Yeah. So, that's that's what these guys plays
uh play. So for us what is important to know
that when someone came to buy options um create
this spikes right is is just imagine you have the
volatility surface someone came and buy options
and create this cone in the volatility surface.
Yes. Why? Because they they take liquidity from
the market and implied volatility increase. Right.
Um so why is that important? Because in the
hedging process obviously we cannot go deep
because we don't have u 30 hours to explain but
as they buy this that create this this spikes and
that attracts the price. Mhm. Okay. And attracts
the price because the market maker needs to buy.
Remember the hedging process. Yes. He needs to
buy. So what happened when they get to the top
of that pig? The market is going to reverse. Mhm.
Why? Because there is no more hedging to do. there
is no more buying. Okay? And the price has to come
back. If you if you think this volatility surface
um imagine that you have a a ball, you know, a
little ping pong or table tennis ball and the ball
moves around that volatility. If the ball goes up
to the pig has to come back. Yes. It's physics,
supply and demand. Yeah. Okay. And the same way
when someone sells options, they sell volatility.
What it means they make options cheap, right? And
when they make options cheaper, they create these
pockets on the surface, right? And the pockets,
what it means that if if you think about the
uh table tennis ball that is moving around that
that kind of surface, it will tend to go to
that pocket. Yes. Okay. That's again physics and
supply and demand in auctions. That's an amazing
information. Once you have that information,
you know what the price is going to do, right?
And for the guys who trade traditionally, volume
profile is this spikes of um buying volatility is
like that um high value nodes. Mhm. Right. Where
they they want to trade these high value nodes
and these pockets of selling volatility is like
the low value nodes. Mhm. you know where they go
to there and then the price spikes for move very
quick to that low volatility and then it spikes
why because there is no buyers there's no volume
you see in the volume profile that kind of yeah
yeah we've had Carman Rosato Fabio Andrea
all show the low volume look how amazing is
we explaining from the volatility surface now uh
spectrum everything comes now to the point where
buying options is buying volatility and crazy
those spikes selling options is crazy pockets.
All right. So, understanding the relationship
between bold surface and spot actually create
trading opportunities. Yeah. um for that's and
that's the work that gu um guess whatot has done
say listen I'm going to take this old information
John and jazz and you know what we're going to do
we're going to put it in a tradable easy way
so we can trade because they never thought to
sell it so we can trade easily now the fact that
zero options are more than 60% nowadays on a $3.3
trillion market Mhm. What it means that if you
manage to get that pick of volatility or pockets
of volatility and you manage to understand that
how is that going to affect the market how is
the market maker what needs to do there. So then
they create this is code you know you you can get
this data free from the CVOE the problem it will
have like 10 15 minutes delayed. Oh okay and the
problem you will have the row data. So what guess
what has done is taken that taken it put a lot of
coding a lot of knowledge um they know a lot you
know honestly after Jim Carson I think these guys
are the ones who know most about the market
and and and they put the knowledge for us to
trade very easily. We're gonna go through some
examples to see, you know, all these, you know,
we try to do it the quick and and easy way, but
it's it's is it's it's a lot to take, but how to
translate this into actionable trading examples.
And I like to think of this as I know it's not,
but it's like playing poker. Mhm. Why? Because
I imagine myself sitting in a table where on my
right I go the market maker. Mhm. And in front of
me I go the institutional guy who put big money
in the market on certain level. Yeah. And he has
to do something. And then on the other side there
is another institutional who knows what I know. So
he's going to play against you know he's going to
do it the same game. But being an institutional
is going to put a lot of money. I'm only going
to put my one or two ENQ contracts. I trade ENQ.
I don't trade micros anymore because with this
um it's amazing with this trading and Q my stop
losses and I know when I teach this to people they
say you're crazy my stop losses are 30 to 40 to
50 ticks that's it there is is that precise that
that's my stop losses they are like oh you put
ATR how many ATR 150 ticks 200 ticks and like
no remember the market maker is going in a F1 car
at 300k per hour. If the market moves in a level,
it has to move. It will move. If it doesn't, you
get out of it quickly. So this is we we um guess
what has create three one two three four or five
kind of models. So the first one which people can
trade options in XPX or they can trade futures on
ES. I trade ENQ basically because when you see I
don't know if you ever seen uh because you trade
foreign exchange but when you see the the charts
on SPX which is the you know S&P 500 500 or the
SPY which is the cheaper contract ETF or NDX or
Q's or ES or NQ when you see when you put all this
graph at the same moment you know they're behaving
in the same so if the market goes up in SPX, SPY
goes up, ES goes up, QQQ goes up, NDX goes up. If
the market gets to a level and then come back,
all of them will come back and and I think it's
this market maker relationship that needs to have
you know that actions actually create that same
structure. Understood. So the spot um that's
why I'm looking XPS for this trade, you know,
for the levels, I'm trading NQ. Mhm. Okay. People
can trade ES of course. Yeah. Yeah. So it's it's
just the same thing. So for instance um have a
look the one on the left you see price on XPX. Uh
by the way this is the platform of guestbot on the
subscription which is called classic. Bear in mind
this is not the same as just getting the data. It
has a lot of coding because remember what we talk
about the market maker he's providing liquidity
and then at the end of the day he goes at the end
of the the the process he goes into the futures to
trade right but what happen if someone come to the
market maker and say listen I want to buy a call
at this strike and then someone else come and say
I want to sell a call at the same strike so the
market maker is not going to h the buying of the
call and then he's going to hedge the selling of
the call. What the market maker is going to do,
he's going to match them. Of course. Yeah.
And then charge the spread from this side,
charge the spread from that side. Fantastic you
guys. But if you think about it, he doesn't need
to do anything on the futures market. Yes. And
as we saw before, there is a relationship between
the futures and the options. So the options
move the spot market, but then as we will see,
the spot market will move the options. So it's a
it's a it's a circle relationship. So on this on
this side what's happened the market went down to
this what is called the max or the pick put gamma.
This these red bars on the left are puts all the
complex of put in the XPX market and the green
ones are the calls. Yeah. So what's the logic? Why
why the price you see came to the put? We can have
it bigger. Yeah. That would be perfect. Um. Huh.
The market came to the put which is called max put
gamma or pickp put gamma. You see what happened?
It's rejected. Try to come back and it's rejected.
Mhm. People who in terms of this particular
example is it the the red dash line? Yeah. That
would be the war. That would be the war. Okay.
That's within zero DT options. This is the put
wall. Yep. Which provides resistance. Anyone who
is trading whatever strategy will and I like to
have this level to get that level. It's taking
all the information we've discussed so far. Oh
yeah. Yep. Okay. You see everything comes to this.
Yeah. Yeah. So well you you did say that so we're
now seeing it. Yeah. So now it's is for instance
for me it's easy to this is this strategy uh we
will see has 75% winning rate and I like to trade
in ENQ okay and with this strategy how frequent
would you say trade opportunities come this one
has one or two trading opportunities in the day
that's it sometimes it doesn't so you don't trade
it but we have another models which I trade more
okay Um but this this this is look if if you don't
have this information you would never know I can't
move that you would never know that this is going
to reverse. Mhm. And why reverse is the question.
Yeah. Everything that we saw but we can use the
board again. Yeah of course. Okay. So why why the
price reverse there? And why do I like to see this
as playing poker? Let let's let's let's keep with
the uh call example so people don't get you know
going to change. So remember this is the payoff of
a call. All right. And this is the strike. Okay.
So this is the institutional. Um let's going to
put it here. The institutional. All right. And
this is the market maker. Mhm. Okay. I love this.
Sorry. This is I love this more than making
money. And imagine um options have something
called convexity which we already talked about
it. So convexity is that exponential exponential
payoff of the options. Okay. So I just wanted
to to to mention it of course. And now imagine
you are an institution right and you decided
to put this call in the market. Yeah. Okay. So
what's going to happen in your portfolio? So you
have one portfolio which is options, right? Let's
call it you bought that call. So you have call
positive. Okay. the market maker who sold that
call. Uh yeah, he's going to have in option. Oh,
he's going to have in options terms still the same
market maker in the options space. He's going to
have the opposite, right? He's going to have cool
negative in his portfolio. But remember because
he needs to hedge his position, he also have an
NQ position. Yeah. Right. Which is positive. So
on NQ, he's going to be positive. Okay. Okay. Now,
gamma this institutional he put the position
out of the money maybe when the price was here.
Once the price get to his level u he's gonna let
me see if I can do it right. He's gonna look at
his gamma profile. This is gamma profile remember.
Yeah. The top of the gamma profile is going to be
his delta which is called delta 50. Why? Because
at the money options which are here options at
the strike they have a delta of 0.5. What does
it really means? It means that actually it's 50%
probability that the option will ended up out of
the money or in the money. It's just a probability
game. But for the institution, if you see the
gamma is the peak of his profit. Okay. So this is
the point where he will make most of his profits.
Mhm. Now you think and you say Freddy, but if the
price keep going higher, he's going to make money
because the price is going higher. Yeah. But
there is two reasons or three reasons to take on
account. First of all, the convexity of the option
means that before it gets to the strike, this
options increase in value exponentially. Yeah.
Up to this point. Mhm. After this point is going
to behave one to one because it's going to go, you
know, same as low. So, it's going to behave one to
one. So, he's not going to make the same amount of
money as he made before. Doesn't make sense for
it to continue. If the market continues to go
up. Yeah. The in terms of the position he has now
to what could happen. Yeah. Under he make let's
let's say it from here to here he make let's put
a number random numbers $100,000. Wow. Yeah. 100k.
But for it to move higher let's say moves the same
distance. Yeah. Right. Let's to put a number. He's
not going to make $100,000. He's probably going
to make I don't know 60,000. Okay. for the same
distance is because that convexity. Yeah. So
that's already a risk for him, you know. Yeah.
Why? Because if the price and that's why the gamma
goes to now you're risking 100 to make 60. Uh kind
of. Yeah. So if you see gamma profile is going up.
Yeah. Up to here and then it start to decrease.
Doesn't mean he's going to lose money. It just
mean he's not going to make the same amount of
money as he made before because of the convexity.
Yeah. Now, okay. Yep. There is something um else
that is okay. He make a lot of money on
the way up because of this convexity. Now,
what happen if the price come backs? He's going
to lose a lot of money as well. Obviously, great
portion of the money he made, he's going to lose
it. Okay? So, these guys are very clever. remember
so they they know when they get here is a good
point to get out. Yeah. Now the second point which
we didn't talk about is called theta decay right
which is like that. So this is the symbol for
theta. This is theta decay. What Tad DK is telling
in zero DT options is like listen you're making
$100,000 but usually like TAD decay um I'm putting
this away TADK has a shape like this you know and
if we think zero DT options start at 9:00 in the
morning oh sorry 9:30 and then they expire at 4:00
somewhere between I would say midday and 1:30 in
the evening this TA decay kind of explode and had
this shape what it means the decay it means that
this option are going to lose value. Mhm. Imagine
that is like the government who is going to tax
your position. Yeah. Right. So that's why options
are complex because people have to be aware of
direction volatility and now time you remember we
talked about that before. Exactly. Yeah. So time
is like you have this and the and every minute the
government sorry about talking about governments
that the government is tax your position. Mhm.
So imagine you already make 100k now you got the
risk that the price come back to you. You're going
to lose your profit and on top of that decay is
going to you know reduce the value of your option
even more. Yeah. So these guys are very clever
and they say you know what are you ready? They
are informed traders. They know these so they say
you know what I get out of here which is what we
see in the screen. Okay. Now what happened when
they get out of the position? So now they sell
the call. This is all at a foundational level
boils down to math right and numbers. So then
these levels they're math. That's it's just all
that math that the institutions have the market
maker has being presented into these levels. Yep.
and and how to trade it is the most important part
like you know understanding and and understanding
that is is important because you see bunch of red
you know red bars more yeah what does it mean well
it doesn't well this this means something but the
fact that this is the major concentration this
one here is telling me this is a big guy there um
I can see but this is billions of dollars on gamma
this this is actually a gamma profile yeah this um
the market expressing gamma terms, right? And this
is telling me just just to give you an example.
Um and and this is early in the morning. You see
this net gamma? Mhm. It means that if the market
moves 1% the market maker would need to go and
hedge $7 billion understood in the future. So can
you imagine how much is 7 billion? That's a lot.
And sometimes it comes to 200 300 billions. Wow.
So, so now you see now people hopefully they they
start to get aware how much money they trade in
the market. It doesn't mean they're going to
trade it, but it means that if the market moves,
they need to h that amount of money. So, back
back to these guys. So, they they h you know,
oh, sorry, they close their position. So, they
say, "Oh, market maker, thank you very much. Do
you remember the call that I bought? Now, I
need to sell it back to you." So, basically,
they get zero position in options. Obviously,
they make the profit. Y and they h the portfolio.
Remember they use this to hedge the portfolios.
Mhm. Now we go to the market maker. So the market
maker say oh okay now I sold an option. Now
I need to buy it back because the guy this
institution is so it's finished. Yeah. Zero.
Okay. So what happened now with the futures?
He's got an imbalance. Yep. So what he needs to
do in order to be delta neutral remember his job
is to provide liquidity not to take positions.
Yeah. So he's got an imbalance of futures. Now
he needs to go to the market and sell futures and
that make those as I say before remember that I
talked about cold walls. Yep. So that's when the
market there is no more options. He needs to sell
futures and that makes the market goes up up. we
get into the cold wall and then there is no more
options to h market is going to finish very soon.
So now he needs to sell futures and that's what
happens. Right? This example is exactly the same
but it's the opposite. He was selling futures on
the way down. Yep. To hes now that the institution
closed his position he needs to go he needs to go
into the market and buy futures and that value
futures create this move. Yeah. And in terms of
this uh particular screenshot is uh time frame
wise like those candles what what time frame is
that representing? One minute. The one minute.
Okay. Yeah. And now we will see how much that
represents on ENQ. All right. Now I got I got here
that that was an amazing day. That happens once
or twice on the day on the week. Sorry. Where we
got the buy. Yep. Now market these levels adjust
though accordingly. No the levels are there. This
is spx levels. What is adjust is the gamma. These
are gamma. Yeah. Gamma gamma lines. Gamma profiles
or gamma values. So will they be your walls? The
walls would be the bigger one. Understood. Yeah.
Either inputs or calls. Mhm. So this example is
actually this one. Market goes to a cold wall.
Yep. Right. And gets there. nothing else to hedge
above and the market reverse, right? Mhm. So if
you if you see this, you say like you when I look
at this and say of course it's this if if it's so
the market has positioned himself to certain level
once the price get there that's it. They call
the day take profits and market maker needs to
sell it balance of futures. Mhm. Now the futures
the formula for options price it has the futures
inside u yeah the the spot. So if the spot is
coming down because the market maker is selling
futures yep that moves the market down. Yeah. All
right. So so again everything that we saw before
is just to trade this. And as I say before,
why I like to see this as a a poker a poker
game because I know what the market maker needs
to do. I know what the institutionals did. Mhm.
And most likely and we can see it here. That's
why I love guest. Yeah. It's amazing. So look
look hang um look as the price hopefully well we
haven't got through the the you know the system
but you know I got the market maker on my right I
know these guys who position themsel here. Yeah,
they what they doing but look there are other guys
who are actually looking at this and they say you
know what we're going to buy calls at this level
just below the no they probably bought it here
when the price was at 7,470 they start to buy call
okay here which is this so imagine this is 7470
Yeah. And imagine this is 7,500. So when the
price went here, what they they are looking at
this. So they buy calls some way. They buy some
structure. They just position themselves here
and look what happened. Look what happens when
the price get there. They just the price reverse
there. Yeah. So actually people who comes to trade
gamma let's it's no gamma but the options flow
through guestbot they if they don't understand
what's happening they probably going to make a
lot of mistakes trading those levels. Mhm. That's
why it's so important to understand what happens
there. Um this is an example what I do. So as I
said before this is on the top is XPX but on the
bottom is NQ. Okay. So basically I take the same
position in NQ. I go long and then on this levels
I go short. Mhm. And and that's it. Do they line
up quite frequently? So like that this one it's is
Yes. On the left you can see it's hit the the wall
on the on the Oh yeah. Because because the wall is
on SPX is not in NQ. That's what I mean. Yeah. So
would you find that they sometimes aren't exact?
No. No. No. Like the walls on SPX and walls
on NQ sometimes. Yeah. But I think the ENQ,
which is the NDX traders, I think SPX being
the biggest market, okay, they probably take
their analysis based on XPX and they position
themselves on on. So with a position like this,
where how would where would you be sort of looking
to execute and put your stop loss and your sort of
take profits? Yeah. So in ENQ I'm looking to buy
at the level once you just buy directly or you
need to see something. I use different things and
um what I mean is if the price is going very um
if the slope of the price is going very hard you
know the slope is is is going with a lot of speed
it's like physics it's going to cross the level
okay so I wait for the level to be recover okay
and then I could have an stop loss by structure
you know below the the wherever that low was yeah
because remember what I say before these levels
they have to go. This is the market maker driving
a F1. If it goes it has to go. Yeah. If it doesn't
get out of it because something else is happening
behind the scenes that we don't see. And usually
that happened and so I take the position in cube.
Now if the price is coming with a low slope more
gentle I know it's not going to break it. It just
kind of How would you describe that one there?
The the top left. Um would you describe that as a
look? But look. Yeah. Look. Oh, sorry. Let me It's
okay. How can I Okay, look what what happened.
We were very fast. Yeah. But I'm far away from my
level. Yeah. And then look, the prices the prices
stop here. Mhm. You know that that that deep uh
move down and then kind of cushion that move.
Yeah. Then it slowly went here, reversed slowly
and then went up. So the I'm going to show you
the positions I take. Okay. So this is basically
here. Mhm. You know, I I I try to take positions
here and put my stop loss below. Okay. Yep. And
then you're are you targeting the the wall on the
the upper side in this example or? Well, I try to,
but as you can see, sometimes the market reverse,
so I like to protect myself. Okay. I like to So
would you say this is quite a fast Oh, yeah. Fast
take profits or scalping? Um well fast 300 ticks,
400 ticks, 500 ticks as long as as I say because
it has to move, you know, it has to take that.
Do you manage similar to how uh Fabio, you know,
quite aggressively like moving your stops into
profit as price to reclaim areas? Yeah. Yeah. I
I usually found it very um profitable strategy
to go in with a few contracts, two contracts.
So I can take profits in one and then leave one
stop loss or break even. Understood? Because to
be honest, sometimes when because I'm trading
in Q, if I go with one contract, sometimes I
take profits and the market do a little bit of
reverse and then keep going higher, of course,
and I'm out of the trade. And obviously ENQ, I
don't know if you trade ENQ or I've seen it. I've
not I've not traded it myself. So one contract
of NQ is a lot of money, you know, is is one
move. You could easily people who doesn't, you
know, take something like this, they, you know,
they I could easily make $2,000, $3,000, but that
means you can also lose them very, of course.
Yeah. Yeah. But with with with these levels, you
know, you can take two or three contracts. Yeah.
Because they know most of the time this strategy
is 75% win rate. Mhm. You know, um why some Oh,
sorry. Why sometimes it doesn't work and I'm going
to show you it. It is that it doesn't work. It's
just like if these guys position themsel lower in
another institution came and put the market even
lower that's going to attract the price. So gamma
levels in an easy way to understand the the the
maximum put gamma and the maximum call gamma are
magnets. Yeah. you know they mag they magnetize
the price because what we see already the market
maker and once they get there they reject the
price because of this. So as an example, let's say
price didn't well it gave a reaction but didn't
follow through and it broke through that level.
You might take a break even or stop loss whatever
it may be. Would you then be looking at this
level as as I will need Yeah. I will need to wait
for this level to be the maximum gamma. Okay. So
then that's when the dashed line comes in. Yeah.
The last you know I got I got a very good example
for you. Perfect. on that um it has a 75 winning
rate and to put in words is because institutional
hedging right options complexity I'm trying to I
didn't miss anything market maker hedging pressure
in the futures market yep because of the gamma
exposure this is gamma exposure on the market
maker yeah u the Greeks which you we already
talked delta gamma and theta decay the time yeah
glad that I didn't miss that uh very fast on zero
option as Mandy, you know, the words of Mandy.
Yes. Yes. Is is is fast. Um because of the actions
of informed traders, you know, like more traders
understanding this now. And I guess more is no
more traders understanding the institutional
traders. Mhm. They they they trade this. Yeah.
Um Okay. So like the institutions using this
knowledge and this formulas that that's the
that's the guy who put you know this that's who's
forming these in the first place. This guy did why
this guy positioned himself here when the price
was down because he knew this. Yeah. And actually
I joke with the guys from Guess what I said like
listen if I have millions of dollars I would trade
this because he saw some strategies that are you
know it's just look again and this is this is the
what you told me before look this was something
happened in the market I guess. Yeah fact reaction
you know it's kind of physics went down very
quick. Mhm. So you don't you don't buy you wait
for the market to come back and then you know you
put your stop loss below here in I put it in NQ.
Yeah. Anyone trading options they can put it here
S sp um they can look at spy QQQs whatever but
they all will have the same structure. Mhm. It's
just a matter of managing your risk um managing
your risk. How many contracts are you going to
pay it? But look what happened. and they just
get to that level and then reject and everything
comes down to the volatility surface and this what
institutions are doing what the market makers need
to do it's like the byproduct of that money flow
understanding what decisions have to be made y
once uh something is either closed out or opened y
look another one so back to your question how many
times you get this on the during the day at least
you have once mhm yeah so I use this strategy to
pass the this funded accounts for these funded
companies because I can I can put 10 ENQ contracts
so I can make $6,000 in one move and that's it. If
the price come back and I'm stop out that's fine,
you know, I got 75% win rate. So I know you move
on to the next one. Exactly. So this is um this
is an example of how I trade S&P in NQ. Yep. So,
I I'm going to show you some of my trades. So,
this trade is SPX, and I took $420 ticks with one
contract, which is $2,000 just by knowing this
level. And talking to what you told me before,
you see, let me see. So, the the put wall was
the put wall was at 5,550. I took my first trade.
Um I didn't I mean the whole move is $2,100 but
because I was hedging I didn't take the whole
it was like $1,800 but then the market come down
right I just put this to see what's the move you
know was what what that levels what moves create
and look what happened they moved the level down
to 7530 Mhm. from sorry 5550 to 5500 uh sorry
5550 to 5530 so what did I do during that time
nothing you know people get in this choppiness
and they get a stop out so with gamma or with
um options float what you do you just wait for the
price to get here and then you buy it some people
ask me oh why don't you take a short position
And I was like because the winning strategy is
here. Mhm. You know, I I like to be here. I like
to I like to enter the market where I understand
what the institutionals are going to do, what the
market maker needs to do and that's it, you know,
is is is is that knowledge that um so that was I
took that one that was 592 ticks. That is almost
$3,000. And with these you're risking between 30
50 ticks which is $150 or $120 you know. So that's
that's the power of this knowledge. Um now I
going to give you some examples not based on
SPX but directly on the volatility surface of the
NDX. Okay. Okay. Um look do nothing. So these two
are my main uh levels. Mhm. As I told you at the
beginning, everything is going to come to a two
lines. Yeah. Right. So, we trade the main biggest
line. Why? Because we know on these levels there
are big eyes with big money placing their bets
in the market there. Is there anything you had to
tweak on the platform to get these levels or it's
just already you you select the currency which is
NDX prices convert to ENQ prices. Okay. So you can
see the ENQ prices, not the NTX. Okay. And that's
it. So you this one is actually open interest,
you know. I'm looking into the open interest. Um
I'm looking into the 90-day open interest. Why?
Because I want to see all the options that are
actually how the whole market has been position
for today's trading day. Mhm. So if this is 9:30
in the morning, New York time, Eastern time, um
I would know that anyone with positions in the
market today, this is the biggest guy. And this
is another two big guys. Yeah. Sorry, I should use
this one. What? Tell me what do I do? Nothing. I
do nothing. I just wait the market to get here and
I buy. That's it. Yeah. So I'm actually changed my
anxiety. You know when people start, oh market is
going to open, 1 minute to open, 1 minute to open.
So I was like, oh my god, just wait. Sometimes I
got levels right where the market opens. I have to
be there or when when it's on the level. Yeah. But
most of the time I just wait for the level. Yeah.
So this is the market open there where the candles
start. Yeah. The market opens here minute candles.
Right. And and that's the other thing that reduce
your anxiety to oh I didn't take the long. Oh,
I didn't take the short. Mhm. You know, people
and that creates anxiety on people and people
start to, you know, make um bad decisions because
they miss the rally, they miss the down. All you
have to do when you trade uh these options flows
is just wait for the level. Wait, wait for the
price to get there. And that that's that one is
478 ticks. That's $2,300. I think if you do that
every day, you're going to be fine. Yeah. This is
another one. So the market, this is telling me the
market is heavily positioning here because there
is a lot of big positions. Yeah. But the one that
we trade is the maximum one, the big one. So what
do you in that scenario? What does the take profit
then mindset you know as price is moving towards
these other big positions. Uh my take profits are
these big guys. These extra levels. Okay. Yeah.
Because what's going to happen? This is going to
happen on those levels. Big guys position there.
I don't I I know these guys are going to do
something here. Yeah, I know the market maker
has to do something and most likely because
the market is going down, they're going to buy
it. Mhm. They're going to profit. Everything is
because these big guys profit and then the market
maker needs to buy. The one who is positioning
here might going to do the same. So the market
might go to this level and then reverse. So I
don't want to lose. I most likely this is going
to be my first target. So this is May 12th and
actually um this market went up to the biggest
gamma which is this one here and make 6363 ticks
which is more than $3,000 you know just by waiting
the level. Um, imagine this remind me of Favio
the trade he was short because of his strategy
and then you know take profits. Don't don't don't
don't stop lossing profit because you're going to
lose. You already called the market on the way
down. Fantastic. But you know what? This is a
wall here. Market is going to reverse. Okay. Uh
this is another example which is quite interesting
because market opens really quick. We got this
massive level which is the biggest one. Yeah. As
as the dash. So the market cross it and then rally
then you sell it. Why? You see you sell the market
because this friction here is is this is just open
the market and and this is a candidate for sell
you know and most people doing technical analysis
we say oh this is the retest you know whatever.
But if you got this level, you want to say, "Oh,
I going to go the short because that's the level."
So the level in itself doesn't say to buy or
sell. It's more so if you're below the level,
you want to Yeah. It's is it's um the study
showing the size. The study that we have done
is most of these levels because of these are
reversals. Yeah. So so the So if you're below,
you if it if you were looking to sell, you would
want to do so when it reaches back. If you're
above when price hits it, you want to be able to
buy. Yeah, it it obviously it will take some times
to Yeah, of course everything to get um you know
to get some knowledge and practice and and see it.
Um but once you have it is is once you have it is
fantastic. So look look this trade 800 ticks where
it goes to the next big level. So which is which
is this one here, right? They actually change it
to here and that that's it. That's enough. You
know that my birthday for April. So I miss it
because I took the days off. Where is my birthday?
Um there is another concept called convexity which
we already study here. Yeah. Now guess what these
guys are very good what because what they do is
they translate everything into this actionable
you know levels. So have a look everything market
start very choppy many people have losses here
market goes down and reverse to where to that
convexity level the ones that we were looking
before were open interest levels these are
convexity levels and this is more close related
to that volatility surface so if I translate this
level on what we learned before is someone bought
options here they make that volatility pay. Okay.
Yeah. Once the price get there is nothing else
for the market maker to buy and the price reverse
which on the classical technical analysis is oh
this is my wave A this is my wave B and I going to
make my way C. Okay. But how it seems a little bit
harder to read the convexity level in comparison
to the previous one. Yeah. Yeah. But this one
works once you learn it is is so what were you
looking for there in that in that sorry you're
totally right the last one's obviously much larger
easy to yeah to identify while this one's quite so
this this this actually the other one classifies
open interest which the biggest concentration of
order um options by contract that works well for
the first two hours and and there is a reason
for that okay but but and it's a mathematical
But convexity this is this this is actually taking
that volatility surface and look that picss in the
surface and that pocket. So the picss on the on
the on the surface are going to be rejections.
Okay. And those are the scan bars. The scan bars
are rejections. So if the price are coming from
below to above most likely this is going to be a
rejection. Okay. The probability of this being a
rejection is bigger that continuation. So if let's
say in this example here if price reach down here
it will be a rejection. Okay. How large do you
need a specific size of that bar or cuz this one
here for example is quite small. Uh what would the
it looks small but there are billions of dollars
there. Obviously I didn't have the I didn't have
the what's the flip side the the purple side on
like this one really here. This is huge. So what
happened? The purple one the scion are buying this
volatility. The purple ones is selling volatility.
So basically this is a map of liquidity. Okay.
This tell this is telling me where people
institutions are taking liquidity from the market.
The scion bars and where are they providing
liquidity to the market. Mhm. So if if if
you allow me to put it somewhere here. So the cyan
bars, these cyan bars, imagine they're a mountain,
right? So imagine you have a ball, right? I like
I like this kind of physics example. Mhm. And you
try to put the ball up. Yeah. What's going to
happen? The ball is going to come down. Mhm.
Why? So it's going to go up. Yep. Down. Right.
Even if it passes, it's going to go down. Okay.
Yeah. So it's going to have that up and down.
Right. So this is the same desion bars is is is
where the price because of that volatility peak
by price is going to get there. There's nothing
else to hedge and then come back down. Mhm.
And the cyan ones which are going to do in red
uh this is a mountain. Imagine their bies. So
the scan bars is selling volatility where the
price easily falls down goes through it you know.
So we don't trade on those because we don't have a
clear understanding in comparison in comparison
to that one. Understood. Yep. Okay. Cool. Nice.
So and look this one we trade we call it positive
convexity the bars. Mhm. Negative convexity the
red the purple ones. So when I when I trade this
convexity I got from positive to positive. Yeah.
Yeah. Positive convexity to positive convexity.
So that trade 384 ticks almost $2,000. Um this
is another one right price came down maximum
positive convexity the mountain and then goes to
the next one and that's it. I I tend not to look
these ones sometimes they go to those ones. That
one seems like quite a small trade right in I say
small in the sense of uh like how long are those
minute candles still? Uh, this is five minute
scandal, so it's 15 minutes. Okay. Yeah. Yeah. So,
we're talking about 420 ticks, which is $2,000 in
15 minutes. So, this one went from here to there.
Yeah. Got you. Yeah. Um, and that's it. What it
goes, Remember, gamma are magnets and rejections.
Mhm. This could go higher, but because I know this
is a rejection, so I do prefer to get out of here,
you know. And if you go with two contracts, I I
guess most of people would be happy with $4,000
in 15 minutes. I'm I'm happy with 2,000 in 15
minutes, honestly. What are your mindsets? So,
like cuz obviously you know the data so in depth
um you know the statistics of your edge like what
is your mindset personally in terms of sizing
you know is that just something regardless of
knowledge it's a tolerance a personal tolerance
that you have to to build and find yourself?
Um yes. Mhm. But funny things when I was an
institutional trader um I I always say this to
people we kind of never they can never spend money
on us on trading you know learning to trade. Mhm.
They say listen do whatever course you do you want
to do but focus on your mind. So I actually took
a very good course the last one on mindfulness
for traders which was kind of hot topic when I
left because uh it was an article of George Soros
and Ray Dalio in Reuters where they mention listen
meditation and mindfulness or mindfulness is what
the best thing we've done the best thing that we
actually help us to get through. So in the city
I start to kind of get this kind of mindfulness
mindfulness. I went to a course of mindfulness and
I told you before I met these guys from Goldman's
from city from these institutions they were like
um um top guys but they were doing the course and
they say listen we're humans and obviously I I
think um what was the name um Ran Hotwall he came
here to talk yeah yeah he came to talk about the
migdala and and and how to calm that migdala and
and that's what we learn I I one day I lost a half
a million dollars in my job. Um the first day they
put me into trade I lost $30,000 even though they
told me your raise is 15,000. So actually I start
to think why why you know what's happening in my
mind why why is that happening? Obvious everything
comes down to the amygdala right to to how that's
actually a survival a fight and flight a survival.
Yeah. and and and in this course I understood
that what's happening is in your body is
um your prefrontal cortex kind of shut down um
so you don't think you don't need blood in your
brain or stomach you need blood in your legs and
arms because it comes down to the caveman where
listen you need to live so you're gonna fight
or fly so you don't need blood in your brain or
stomach and that's why When you people are getting
happen to us, it happens to everyone. You know,
we're getting close to our stop loss. You get that
sensation in your body, but it's actually cortisol
spike spy telling your body you need to fight
even though you're sitting in front of a computer,
right? But that's the nature of of um of the our
mind doesn't know the difference, right? Danger
or or uh safety. Yeah. And that's when people
take revenge trades, you know, they move the
stop loss because they they is this fight. So you
say mindfulness is really the practice of being
aware and present enough to know what when you're
getting to those edges. So basically the good
thing about gamma is my stop losses are 3050 tick.
which is I'm risking $150, sometimes $200 to make
$2,000. Yeah. So that's that's kind of one to 10.
But I also have a stop losses. Of course, this is,
you know, I made mistakes. So I I I've been
practicing mindfulness since then. It's been I
don't know more than eight years. And that helped
me to understand that when I have a stop-loss,
it's very hard on me because to be honest, I have
a stop-loss every two or three weeks. I have one
stop loss, which is not good because I'm I'm I'm
used to winning. So when if one happens slightly
more frequently, yeah, if one happens because it
doesn't happen quite often, it's really bad. I
I feel terrible and I know myself and I know I
need to shut down the platform and I just need
to leave because I know nothing I can do. Amigdala
is there. Cortisol is there. The revenge need is
there. If I stay in my desk, that's it. That's the
end of my account. So would you say even having
such depth of knowledge of the markets but and
your stats and the statistics regardless our human
nature you need to tap into that and understand
yourself? Yeah. Um because equally there could be
another trader, same knowledge, same strategy,
everything, but maybe their risk tolerance is
slightly higher or they're able to handle the
losses better. So therefore, they can make their
rules around them. Yep. Yeah. So I think there's
a misconception that people assume once you have
say data or strategy or edge, you know, it becomes
easy. But in reality, the human nature element is
very different to every trader. Yeah. On the other
hand, we all are the same. We have the amigdala,
which is the the only function of the amigdala
is to keep us alive. Yeah. And survive as a human
especially. Yeah. Trading, you know, that's why
95 97% of the traders the first year they blow
up their accounts and they do why? Because we're
humans and there this the my own philosophy and
analysis is we are not built to be traders. Yeah.
Humans are not built to be traders and that's why
so many people lose. Some people you know talking
about statistics are on the normal distribution
on that tail that they are being so good like for
instance the most of the successful traders you
have interview they have something in common and
I guess is the fact that they are very good risk
managers yeah exactly they know when the stop loss
come that's it tomorrow is another day I remember
one guy do interview he say when a guy when when
he has a stop loss he stopped for two days and
that's very sensible cuz you need your body to
dec, you know, to clean. Mhm. And your mind trying
to get back to neutral. Yeah. You probably have
a very good a very bad stop loss that at the time
was really hurting, you know, got your feelings,
your emotion probably you don't remember now, you
know. Exactly. And that's why you need time to to
clean. So I do practice mindfulness. I do practice
my I like Ray Dalia when he said I like to think
myself outside my body and look what I'm doing.
Yeah. So I try to do that because when you trade
you're like kind of in this universe be that's why
Randy says to record yourself. Yeah. You know so
you can see yourself tensing up or the heart rate.
I'm actually use a heart rate. Yeah. He said the
same. So I got my monitor and I know when it when
it goes higher my heart is you don't see it unless
you have something to monitor. So I think it's
it's quite important and and actually the people
who actually take my the people I have coached
in South America I I like to bring this to the
Spanish community because it's very difficult to
find this information let alone in Spanish. Yeah.
Exactly. Yeah. So I give to them my eight weeks uh
which I learn here my eight weeks training of
the mindfulness. Yeah. Yeah. I try to do that
for them. But anyway back to this. This is a 420
tick trade and I put this because I use I use this
platform to trade ATS to trade order flow which
because I think I wanted to see when the market
maker comes into the futures what do I see in the
futures you know what what footprint can I get
so I I was learning this platform unfortunately I
paid a lot of money I get into the hands of these
guys who charge a lot of money to teach you you
know things that don't really explain the market.
But anyway, the good thing is I use the platform
and I can see when this market maker comes into
the market for instance um probably you have heard
from Fabia as well the big trades. Mhm. Yeah.
Yeah. So have a look. This is what a traditional
trader see. So you see big trades here,
big trades here, big trades here. Yeah. You know
big trades everywhere. So how how you know I found
it difficult people who trade big trades but um
this is actually a trade I took and I and I bring
it here on May 15 did nothing until the price went
to major level and then I took the long right but
on the platform on this big trades what I saw look
the difference between these big trades trying to
take a long position because you might think they
are what is called trap sellers yeah actually has
a higher probability of success when you have this
major major level given by the options. Mhm. This
is this is like an easy trade and and I'm sorry to
say this. I don't want to sound echocentric, but
it really is an easy trade. You know, you go you
go here have that alignment. Yeah. And then you go
your level. Just go long and put your stop loss
here. Mhm. Now, what people call trap sellers,
this is just the market maker here. you know, does
the market maker put in a bid because he know in
advance that all these guys he knows in advance
that the guys position there Yeah. they might
going to take profits. Mhm. So I do truly believe
hopefully I'm not going to get um revealing the
mysteries of the market makers. But they're here.
They're in the bit. Yeah. Right. They're waiting
and and because they know now they have all the
futures they sold on their way down, they need to
buy it back. Yeah. And that creates the move. So
this is this is going long here and put a target
here. So this this is the trade when you combine
with you know what people see in order flow or
footprint. Um I got another one. Oh, so that was
the same day I took this trade went for lunch. I
was working on my course and and things. And when
I came back to launch, I saw the price was really
close now to the next level. Yeah. So I said,
"Okay, now you know what was there taking the
short based on what we saw the same logic. So I
took the short and I went to the next level. Even
though the market keep going lower, that's fine.
I just took the short 300 ticks is is enough for
after lunch having a coffee and trade that." Mhm.
Um I'm talking about NDX and there is a reason why
I trade NDX because an NDX contract compared to
so the two how can you trade or how can people
trade options um following the NASDA is they can
do it through NDX and QQQs. The difference is one
contract on QQQ one standard deviation in in in at
the money could be $60 to $70 one contract. Yes.
And the S could be $10,000 or $12,000. So if you
think about it, who is going to come to the market
to trade $1,000, $10,000 a big guy? Yeah. And
I've seen then they come and put 600 million,500
million, $900 million in gum exposure. That's
going to move the market of course guaranteed.
But now recently with just which is the um the
futures trader and guestbot um we are actually
looking at QQQ because look look what QQQ does as
well. Mhm. So our my theory and my hypothesis is
very clever about traders in options um and what I
mean traders I mean funds um you know CTA accounts
these kind of mutual funds, hedge funds, pension
funds which are not as big as the other ones. They
analyze the market with the volatility surface
as I show you and they take positions on on QQQs
as well. Yeah, based on what they see in SPX or
NDX and have a look at this. This is again this
is the same you know what people call patterns I
guess price get who is there the market maker is
is is no sell uh trap sellers is the market maker
in an important level going to the next level. So
it went to the remember the pick pocket on the
buying volatility. Yep. So imagine the surface
we got to pick uh not pocket pick um pick a
spike you know this spike that creates this
cone. So the price go reverse to where where
there is a pocket of volatility which is the
purple line. Mhm. And that's funny because that
day I did it twice and did it here. Profits here.
I bought again and I put it here. And that's what
normal uh or traditional traders say. Oh that's
a double bottom. Yeah. Well, it's not a double
bottom. It's actually positioning positioning,
right? Um and I think um obviously didn't have
time but um there is another two tools that we use
which is called guessbot order flow and did you
remember the volatility? Do you remember the ball
skew? U if you cut it and you take a slice you
get a volatility skew. So you get the volatility
surface in 3D. You cut it, you get the volatility
skew. That volatility skew which is this one here
basically is telling you supply and demand in the
options traded transacted and the other one is
quoted. So what the market makers at quote this
we go back a little bit to the fundamentals but
analyzing this is also analyzing you know how can
we trade this and guess got a very good they're
working there they're going to launch it where we
can actually going to trade this we're going to
trade the volatility cube which is this this one
is just a visual representation but we're going
to trade it with high probability as we trade
gamma levels we're going to trade this you know
the same level, you know, saying we're done the
whole day to come back to two levels. They do it
with volatility. And this is um back to the call
example when an institution came and buy a call,
it's going to make an effect on market maker.
So basically this order flow measured up and for
instance you know you don't see this but I mean
if if you're a traditional trader you don't see
it but here someone with a 100 million in gio the
b volatility. Mhm. So it's the same concept you
get the coin what's going to happen on this move
is going to be reversal. Yeah. So we trade this
we trade oh someone came $100 million that's a lot
of money is going to reverse the market. Mhm. most
likely. So, probably next time. Yeah, definitely.
So, you know, and and just to finish up, um,
every trader and I I wanted that's why I put this
slide because I'm um in my Spanish course, I go
options traders and they had no idea about this. I
don't know. They they teach them how to trade with
Ballinger bands and I'm like probably you get
a grasp of what is options. Yeah. How can you
trade moving areas and options and binger bands on
options? This is very important to know the bull
events which is the opex which is monthly. Yep.
Why? Because all these options expire and the
institutions they roll over or they let expire you
know they let it to expire on that day. Mhm. But
the market maker needs to do something. So these
days I keep on on on my mind because as I told you
before there are the days where traders, oh today
the market was really hard. Oh my goodness, that
was choppy. Yeah, it was OPEX. Mhm. You didn't
know triple witching which is the third Friday of
March, June, September and December. Why is that
important? Because that's on that day options on
indices, options on single stocks and on options
on futures expire. Mhm. So you got three assets
that three derivatives on the same day. What the
market is going to do? Roll it over. Okay. Expire.
Okay. But the market maker is there doing this
buying and selling on the futures. So that day I
don't work that day especially because that day
we don't have zero dy options. I don't have an
age. So I don't trade. I go with my wife to have
an ice coffee. uh bispiration is very important
because it's the Wednesday that um exactly
30 days before the third Friday all connected
and that's the spir the expiration of um bigs uh
options on the big index. Mhm. Why so important?
Because they spire at 9:30 Eastern time. Yeah. So
basically they spire when the market opens. Mhm.
What I have noticed, I don't have data, but if the
market goes down, it will continue. You know those
days when the market start to go down down down
and never reverse. Yeah. Most likely are those
days or it start to go up up up. Why? Because
there are millions of dollars on these contracts
expiring the market maker is doing that and you
know there is an inverse relationship between
the bigs and the indices. So they have a negative
relationship. Yeah. So look, we got these billions
of dollars expiring on the bigs that's going to
move the index of course and the last one that we
talk everyone in everyone trading options in this
way knows and are very aware of the JP Morgan the
equity fund $22 billion they hedge it on the end
of March June September and December end of the
core yeah so that you have to this is the bull
events that you need to be aware and they're in
this um if you Google CBOE 2026 options calendar
you will get it. Yeah. Uh so people need to be
aware of that and well thank you and absolute
pleasure. No Freddy this has been a in-depth true
uh master class and a massive insight not only for
me but I'm sure for the audience as well hopefully
you know and this is I know as you mentioned
like this is a fraction of what you could dive
deep into and you know we're excited to get you
on chart academy and have a more in-depth view
over there. Uh, so make sure you check that out
as well. Fabio's over there as mentioned earlier.
Randy How's over there as well. All for free
just like this. And again, a huge massive thanks
to you Freddy and for all the work that you're
doing not only in the Latam community but here
as well with us and just generally sharing such
in-depth knowledge from your experience. It's an
absolute pleasure and no doubt helping the overall
industry improve not only in their knowledge but
also showcasing what real trading really is
about and what to focus on. So fantastic. No,
thank you so much. Thank you for your invitation.
I'm really happy. You know, when when I left the
institutional war and came to the retail, I is,
you know, like like really, let's put it this way,
I'm Colombian. What really breaks my heart, broke
my heart is is is people trying to do a living on
trading and and they get these, you know, gurus
selling things that, you know, doesn't make sense,
of course, and they spend thousands of dollars of
this. So, I was trading. I went back to Colombia.
Um I knew I could do this. I kind of knew with
my heart. Um we didn't have information as you
can believe. You can imagine which this kind of
information is the war for three four years with
the guys from Guess what amazing guys and and at
that time I didn't have much information but I was
trading in my in my apartment and then a friend
of mine came and said what are you doing? And
I was like, you want to learn? And he he did an
Spanish interviewing in to me in his uh YouTube
channel. And from that on all the Spanish people
were starting like you know, Spanish speaking like
like you know like get because when you when you
see this actually makes sense. Yeah. You know,
well it's backed by not only data but then the
results are there as well. um and the experience
and unfortunately not only in the Latam community
but just generally within the trading community
you know there's so much marketing and lifestyle
and again them being promoted strategies that
don't have any either verifiable results or data
behind it even sometimes both which is even worse
so I like to think that when people who really
are passionate about trading even if they're not
profitable yet uh but they really are passionate
about trying when they come across someone like
yourself someone like Fabio Valent Ini or Carmine
Rosato or like people who are genuine and have
that data and have the results as well. People
then are drawn to them. They then start to get
educated and have a stronger awareness of what
real trading looks like which is great for the
industry because then the more people who have
that awareness and that almost awakening if you
will the more hopefully we'll make a difference
you know. Yeah. And this is just a start like like
the guest like the I like I like Jim Carson words
it's no gama it's just the options flows influence
on the market and this is just starting the wave
is just starting we are just starting to get this
knowledge that institutions had and they don't
share obviously but we just we just we just get
into it and and honestly as I said to you before
I'm lucky because I came into this not with the
need of money with the need to soul you know solve
the puzzle and when I think you know it it really
like kind of I feel very happy because people
send me test or send me message I remember two
in particular one lady said I never made $5,000
in my life in a day and and she was like thank
you thank you thank you thank you and and I told
my wife I said this is you know bring me happiness
and and the last one was a guy uh trading
options with his wife they sent me a message
We never had a green wig in a year. We never never
and they say it's amazing that we have a green
wig. It's they told me it's just amazing. And and
one Italian guy he told me Freddy this he's in my
course. He said that looks that looks illegal. And
I said well it's it's here for you. That's what
we like. Freddy, I appreciate you. We'll be glad
to have you back as well. We're going to shoot a
Words of Risom right now. Everyone at home, drop
a comment with your biggest takeaway from this
episode. Any questions you might have, I'm sure
there'll be many. Drop them in the comments cuz me
and Freddy will take a look and maybe that will be
part two or we'll form that into Char Academy, but
we'll make sure to to cover that as well. Links
for Freddy are in the description below. Go show
him some love. Links also for Gexot by then will
no doubt be in the description below also because
we're going to connect with them guys. Oh yeah,
actually actually I got a very good offer. Um,
I'm going to put a link where they can test it
for one month with 65% discount. You got it. So,
they can actually don't need to trade it.
They just put the levels what we show it
here and then you can see keep track and and
you see your strategy and see how it fits. So,
these guys actually give me a 65% discount for
everyone who want to have a look the and and
and and the important thing is I don't work for
Guess what. I I've been talking to these guys
and I'm very very very um you know grateful
because learn a lot from them. We you know we
learn together as well. But um they they are in
the move to they need to teach people. They are
not in the move to to make profits. They just
say we need to teach people. We need to make
people more aware and and they give me you know
what 65% so they can they can test it and they
can have a look at and and I'm sure people will
love it. Well, hopefully we'll see them on here
as well or somewhere in the future as also. Yeah,
definitely. Everyone, until next time, everyone.